After the SDV gets as close as it can, dispose of it.
From there on, you'll have to swim.
High tech special forces unit Foxhound.
Your former unit, and one that I was a commander of.
So they're still around.
There are six members of Foxhound involved in this terrorist activity.
Psycho Mattis, with his powerful psychic abilities.
Sniper Wolf, a beautiful and deadly sharpshooter.
Decoy Octopus, master of disguise.
Vulcan Raven, giant and shaman.
And Revolver Ocelot, specialist in interrogation, and a formidable gunfighter.
And finally, in charge of them, Foxhound's squad leader.
Liquid Snake.
Liquid Snake?
The man with the same code name as you.
The nuclear weapons disposal.
It covers the whole island.
I'll instruct you by codec after you reach your target.
Anyone going with me?
Don't look at my panties.
This is a one man infiltration mission.
Weapons and equipment OSP?
Yes.
This is a top secret black op.
Don't expect any official support.
That's just like my real head.
Oh my god.
Why do you swim like that?
I'm as elegant as a dolphin.
What are you talking about?
Hello everybody!
Welcome back!
Welcome back to Metal Gear Solid Integral.
Press the start button.
Welcome back, welcome back, welcome back.
Did you notice something a little special about the game?
Isn't it cold AF in Alaska in your main outfit?
Don't worry.
I'm a ghost.
It doesn't even matter.
Snake is cute.
He's always cute.
What are you talking about?
Seems pretty normal to me.
Yes.
I am playing the...
mod swapped version.
Where I will be!
Solid Snake!
Oh, no, no, no, no, no!
No more.
There we go.
Okay.
Hello boss.
Good to have you with us.
So...
Actually...
Jeremy hooked me up with like a save...
of where I was at exactly basically.
So...
We're just picking up where we left off.
But instead of Snake, it's me.
So...
Thank you.
Thank you guys for helping me out with getting this all set up.
Especially in time for the finale.
Ghosts don't belong in Alaska.
So...
Yeah.
I'm so excited.
And nervous.
Let's see.
Let's see how it looks.
Oh my gosh.
Now we don't need the...
The mission log...
The lition...
Mog.
Mom!
I made the...
Wait.
Can I Beyblade?
No.
I'm so excited.
Letter rip!
Yay!
Are you also a liquid snake?
Since their...
Wait.
Oh.
It disappeared.
What the heck?
Thank you for the sabotage!
Yeah!
Here I go.
Oh my gosh.
Look at me!
In the future, I should commission a...
Like...
Me in a sneaking suit.
Oh my gosh, look at me!
Look at me!
Okay, got my stuff.
I got full rations.
I got my other stuff.
Okay, we're all good, I think.
Look at me!
It's so cute!
I did not expect a vent mod.
It's pretty awesome, right?
Oh my gosh, mom!
I'm in the game!
Oh my gosh, it's so awesome!
Man!
Oh, I already have rations.
Wait, how's my health anyway?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, full.
We're set to go, baby.
We're set to go.
The legendary Solid Mint.
Yes!
So today we will be completing Metal Gear Solid.
We got a little bit to go, so it'll be a little bit.
But hopefully we can believe in my gamer abilities.
My abilities as a soldier.
As a gamer.
Congrats on debuting on your first of many Metal Gear universe on livestream.
Love can bloom on the battlefield.
Solid Mint is a ghost.
Why doesn't she go?
Go through the walls to stop Rex.
Fake ghost.
Hey, I'm doing this fair and square, okay?
Fair and square.
But, yeah!
So...
I don't really know what else to say.
I'm nervous about fighting Vulcan Raven.
Because he's so difficult.
But...
I'll do my...
My roux bestie.
How do I look in the box?
It probably looks the same, right?
Oh, you can see my little feet!
Yeah, it looks the same.
Right?
Oh, man!
What would be funny?
All of the Metal Gear series that is 3D changes Snake to Mint.
After this game, Peace Walker to MGS3.
I don't know.
A 4 and 5 modded... Once I get a 3D model, maybe we can put it in...
I feel like by the time I get around to playing 5...
By the time I get around to playing 5...
I will have to have a 3D model by then, right?
No sneaking suit during the liquid fist fight, right?
How is that gonna...
How is that gonna look?
Wait...
Jeremy!
Are they gonna take off my clothes?
Wait!
Am I gonna be...
Finally get my undies?
What's going on?
No...
Oh, man.
You are not gonna be naked.
Man, you had an opportunity!
You had an opportunity!
Maybe you should fix it...
For when everybody else uses this mod.
Can't wait for Metal Gear 1 and 2 mod.
I'll be there no matter what.
You won't be streaming on my birthday.
Happy early birthday!
I'll sing real fast so we can suddenly get into the...
I'm quite busy today, actually.
I was like, Oh my gosh.
Should I be even streaming such a long thing?
Because I have so much to do before tomorrow.
But...
It's okay.
Instead, I...
Instead, I edited a video that I didn't need to necessarily put out.
And then, also, I worked on this.
So, you know...
I think I used my time wisely instead of packing and practicing.
Whatever.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Wii U.
Happy birthday to Wii U.
Alright, guys.
I don't remember the strat for beating Vulcan Raven, so...
I think it's like, just put C4 down and don't forget where you put it.
Oh my gosh, we're gonna see the cutscene with me.
This is gonna be crazy.
Why is my mouth, like...
like a cat shape?
Oh my gosh, I can't see anything.
Oh my gosh, it's so bright!
My eyes!
Welcome, Cossack.
This is the end of the road for you.
Right, my friends?
Listen, baby.
Happy birthday, dear Wii U.
Happy birthday, dear Lime.
Very sick!
Deserves all the thanks for getting this thing off the ground.
Thank you.
Thank you so much!
I feel like crying, I'm so happy.
It's so funny because I look so anime in this.
That's an eagle.
Oh!
I look so... everybody doesn't have an eye...
Oh my god!
This is...
The raven's on me!
I'm a Japanese princess!
Oh my gosh, my eyes are so...
I can't move!
I'm a Japanese princess!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you for the five gifts!
Thank you!
Yes!
You live in Alaska too.
I do.
Do you know of the World Eskimo Indian Olympics?
Yeah, I know it.
Must be a real thrill in the Muk-Tuck eating contest.
Yes, you are right.
But there is another event that I excel at.
It is called the Ear Pool.
It is an event where two opponents pull each other's ears while enduring the harsh cold.
Never would have thought of that.
You test spiritual as well as physical strength.
The ear pull.
You want to pull each other's ears?
I look so smug!
Rejoice, snake!
Ours will be a glorious battle.
This isn't glorious.
It's just plain killing.
Violence isn't a sport.
Yeah, violence isn't a sport!
We'll see if there's iron in your words.
Uh oh.
Oh my gosh.
I'm not ready.
I'm not ready for this battle.
Oh my gosh.
Don't see me!
Okay.
Let's see.
Does stun grenades work on him?
I have quite a bit, actually.
Run, Mito, run!
On
the claymores, I won't remember where I do it!
I don't remember.
Stuns don't work.
Okay, okay.
Maybe I can Nikita missile him.
And remember that that's technically a way you can do it.
Let's see.
Oh my gosh.
He's coming this way!
Wait, he knows where I am!
How does he know where I am?
Run, Mito, run!
Okay.
How do I shoot this thing again?
Oh no!
It's all in...
It's not...
Okay, so the master collection would make it to be like AB.
XY.
Okay, so X is A.
Square is X.
Oh gosh.
B is O.
Y is triangle.
This will confuse me, surely.
This surely won't confuse me.
Oh my god.
Where is he?
Don't come this way.
Maybe if I leave...
Okay, maybe if I bait him...
For the... C4.
Okay.
Wait, okay.
Square button and then B button.
Okay.
Bait, bait.
Bait him, bait him, bait him.
Wait, what the hell am I wearing?
On my head.
Oh, that's my hair.
Go up.
No!
Don't go!
Hey, man.
Hey, you're going the wrong way!
Okay, let's try Nikita missile again.
I remember struggling on this quite a bit.
Where is he though?
Oh my god.
There he is.
Ah!
You son of a gun.
Wait, wait, wait.
He's coming back.
He can...
Cause...
Come on.
Go up, go up, go up.
He shot the missile, Minto.
I know, I saw.
Go up, go up.
Go up towards me, go up towards me.
Yeah, nice, nice, nice, nice.
This is actually good.
This is actually pretty good.
Keep going, keep going.
Maybe I should have put one where I just stood.
Okay, hold on.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna put one right here.
Slow and steady, everybody.
Slow and steady.
Wait, where did I put it?
Right here, in the middle, in the middle, in the middle, in the middle.
Okay, in the middle.
Wait, no, he's coming up through the middle.
Turn!
Turn like... turn to the right.
Yes, yes, yes!
Wait, I'm gonna put one... here?
Oh wait, it's gonna explode the first one though, right?
Oh shoot.
He's going in the same pattern.
I wonder if he'll...
I'm right here, dummy!
Snake looks cute.
My hair is so green here.
Wait, sorry.
Okay.
Put down.
O button.
Oh god.
Oh no, he's doing his little running bit now.
Oh my god.
You're scaring me.
I'm gonna put one down here again.
He seems to like to come over here.
Oh my god.
Come over here!
What?
He's like huffing and puffing.
I think he's struggling.
What the?
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Oh, nice.
You jerk!
Maybe I could have gotten him, but...
Does knocking lure him?
I don't think so.
Dang.
Oh my god, oh my god.
I know this is like the slowest ever, but...
Stop running.
Why are you running?
Oh my god.
Come on up.
I'm luring a cat.
And like, this is exactly what it's like to call for a cat.
They just don't listen to you.
Remember the basics of CQC.
Against this guy!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Come on!
Oh!
Nice!
Oh, he's still going.
Oh, he's still running.
Oh my god, he's still running.
Stop running!
You're scaring me!
Oh my god.
Which way is...
Ah!
You're scaring me!
Oh my god, oh my god.
Stop running, Raven.
Please, Vulcan Raven, please!
He's really getting his cardio in, man.
He's like going at it.
Come on, come on.
Come on, come on, come on!
This is the strat.
Ah!
Oh, it did barely, but that's okay.
I'm sorry.
I'm so scared of him.
I think I put it...
Oh, dang it!
Wait, where did I put it actually?
In...
Okay, right there, right there.
Sorry, I have to be like really meticulous... or slow about this.
You know, meticulous, because I will forget otherwise.
Okay.
It's mint mode!
Oh!
Hold on!
Everybody, hold your horses.
Come on, he's going up!
He's going up!
Oh my god!
I accidentally put another one down.
It's right here.
It's right there.
I might have to go find some more.
Oh my gosh!
Don't find me.
Don't see me.
Okay, I'm gonna have to blow this one up first.
Alright, come up here.
Here's the claymore.
I'm afraid of running over it though, for real.
That was close.
Don't come down.
I said no, don't come down.
Alright, now go up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Keep going up.
Nice!
This is how we do it, guys.
We're almost there!
We're gaming!
Claymore's in the inner range.
Look at him running around like crazy.
Paperbacks!
Thank you for the five gifted!
I know I should set up some more, but it's also like getting it... It's fine, you guys.
It's fine.
He's running around so... He's like so tired.
Keep going up!
Nice.
This is not speedrun strats, but that's okay.
Oh my god.
Wait.
No, he's...
He is.
Put a claymore in his path.
I'm so scared.
I'm so scared of getting blown out.
Oh, my rations are frozen!
Oh, shoot.
Okay, hold on.
I'll put one... here.
Oh my gosh.
Scary, scary, scary, scary, scary.
Okay.
Um...
Uh... C4.
Okay.
He's coming up, I think.
He's gonna come up.
I have to be careful, though, not to...
Not to get blown up by the claymore.
If he comes around.
It's fine.
It's good.
Oh.
What was that?
He can see the claymores too, though, right?
Okay.
I'm gonna run.
Ah!
Oh my god.
This is... Oh, this is bad.
Oh, my rations are free, though.
Yeah!
Oh, oh, bitch!
No!
Go back to where?
Wait.
Okay.
Did that ever blow up?
Oh my god.
Wait a second.
Oh.
Uh.
Wait.
It's a... Okay.
Square button.
Here he comes.
Maybe.
He's... He's close.
He's close.
You exploded your C4.
Not me, right?
Oh my god.
Don't come up here.
Unless you do.
He's exploding my hiding spot!
Here he comes.
Just as the boss said.
It is my existence which is no longer needed in this world.
Nice.
First try.
Yippee!
My body will not remain in this place.
My spirit and my flesh will become one with the ravens.
In that way, I will return to Mother Earth.
I was so nervous I was shaking.
I think it's also from...
I'm hungry.
Snake!
I will be watching you!
Yippee-yo!
Understand?
Devon, thanks for the 10 giftis!
Snake, take this security card.
It will open that door.
Why are you helping me?
Why?
You are a snake which was not created by nature.
I look so happy.
You and the boss.
You are from another world.
A world that I do not wish to know.
Go and do battle with him.
I will be watching from above.
First, I'll give you a hint.
A hint?
The man who you saw die before your eyes.
The diaper chief?
Stinky.
That guy!
Oh my god!
Why me?
Whoa!
Yeah, the diaper chief.
I like the cat mouth.
That was not the diaper chief.
But I just said it was the diaper chief!
Mint, do something!
A member of Fox House.
Decoy octopus?
Easiest boss battle ever.
He was a master of disguise.
He copied his subjects down to the blood.
That's why he was drained of blood!
So he drained the chief's blood and took it into himself.
Nasty!
Oh my god, his face!
Oh my god, oh my god.
But he wasn't able to deceive the angel of death.
The angel of death?
What did you do with his body?
Killed him with cringe.
He's like, anime!
Anime!
Why go to so much trouble?
Why impersonate the chief?
That is the end of my hint.
You must solve the rest of the riddle yourself.
Peculiar how...
this part's still metal.
In the natural world, there's no such thing as boundless slaughter.
There's always an end to it.
You are different.
What are you trying to say?
The path you walk on has no end.
Each step you take is paved with the corpses of your enemies.
Their souls will haunt you forever.
You shall have no peace.
So awesome!
Look at me go!
My spirit will be watching you.
They gobbled that guy up!
They ate him so fast.
Master Miller?
Snake, it's me.
Master.
It's about Naomi.
Turn the monitor off.
What about Naomi?
Colonel, is Naomi there?
No, she's away.
She's taking a short nap.
Oh, she must be nice.
I'm fighting for my life and she's napping.
Okay.
Maybe we'd better let the Colonel hear this too.
I'll be watching you.
Subs to my channel.
And I'll let you know when she's gone.
Well, basically, Dr. Naomi Hunter is not Dr. Naomi Hunter at all.
What?
I thought her story of her background sounded kind of fishy, so I checked it out.
And?
There is an actual Dr. Naomi Hunter.
Or I should say, there was one.
But she's not the woman we know.
The real Naomi Hunter disappeared somewhere in the Middle East.
Our Naomi must have somehow obtained her identification papers.
Uh-oh.
So then who is she really?
She must be some kind of spy.
A spy.
Yes.
Maybe she's been sent to sabotage this operation.
Are you saying she's with the terrorists?
I don't want to believe it either.
But she is working for Foxhound.
So you think she had a part in the uprising?
Or she could be working with some different group altogether.
Different group.
It couldn't be.
Place her under arrest.
What?
She's betrayed us.
She needs to be arrested and interrogated to find out who she's with.
She's one of their spies and we're in big trouble.
What do you mean?
Nothing.
Have you let her in on some kind of vital secret or something?
Colonel!
Does this have anything to do with the mysterious deaths of the DARPA chief and the arms tech president?
I have no idea.
Colonel!
Anyway, we cannot allow her to participate any further in this mission.
Wait, wait a minute.
Without her, we can't complete this mission.
Why not?
You're hiding something.
Give me some time.
I'll try to get it out of her.
Hurry then.
We've got to figure out who she is and what she's doing here.
I understand.
Colonel!
Give me some time.
We're out of time!
Yeah!
Oh, I love that.
I don't have any time left for you.
It's so awesome.
Oh, my health is like... there's still ration and stuff over here though, right?
We'll just take this.
Let's go around and grab some stuff.
All good.
Oh, what's that?
I'm cute on my shoulders.
Nice.
Take the minigun.
Oh, there we go.
Wow.
No wonder he's like huffing and puffing around.
Oh, so good!
I like that there's a way to, like, look at each corpse, you know?
Thanks for the fine gift, Toad!
So, guys...
It was a slow process, but we gamed.
And now, we continue.
Onward.
What do I... how many... let's see.
Okay, 17 chaff grenades.
And we'll get more, later.
We'll need one for that one room coming up.
Oh, I forgot to say this.
Ah-hoo-hoo-hoo, said the crow.
Is that...
Is that the sound crows make?
Um, please, no spoilers.
Not for me, but for anyone who is watching that hasn't played...
the series before.
If you see a spoiler, please...
use to...
um...
get it off the screen.
Thank you!
There you go.
Pen.
Oh, right.
Oh, wait.
Thank you, Joshua!
Have you ever heard of God?
Yes!
The one that...
David Hayter is...
Yeah!
That plays.
I have.
I haven't watched it yet, though.
Um, this is so funny.
Okay.
So, like I said...
They gave me this save because, um...
Because...
Uh...
Obviously, this is not from the Master Collection.
But, um...
There's no Nastasha.
There's no Meryl.
There's no Meryl in here.
I don't know anything about Dr. Naomi.
So there's not much I can say.
Okay.
But, Snake.
I think you'd better leave that to Colonel Campbell.
Don't you think you'd better just get to the control room?
Fine.
Okay.
Master.
Mr. Miller.
Snake.
I'm sure that woman calling herself Naomi is some type of spy.
And now I'm starting to think that Campbell might be hiding something, too.
Don't trust him.
Oh.
You're making me nervous.
Check the back of the box.
Naomi wasn't acting strangely or anything?
No.
I just can't believe that Naomi is an enemy spy.
I refuse to accept that.
I don't want to believe it, either.
But...
Don't say it, Snake.
My favorite spoiler about this game is the part where the metal gears become solid.
It's so impactful.
Yeah.
It's a really good part, you know?
Save Achoo.
Oh.
She doesn't even say anything.
Nothing gets said to me.
First time watching MJ's gameplay.
I didn't know the character that David Hader voices in this particular game is so cute.
So cute.
I know I won't be bored with the next about.
Wasn't it kind of surreal though?
Snake, if it's about Naomi, I'm looking into the matter right now.
We don't have time, colonel!
Where is she?
She's still sleeping.
What?
Wake her up!
First, the DARPA chief turns out to be an impostor and now Naomi.
Nastasia...
Who is this?
And the save is in L.A., just finishing up the episode.
I'm so disappointed in you, Colonel.
I'm so disappointed in you.
I think I got everything that I can get from this area, so let's just move onwards.
Level 7 now, baby!
Let's go!
Okay.
That's a trap.
Oh, look!
They even gave me some more!
Because they know that this room is just ridiculous.
Look at this!
What is going on in here?
Even if I shoot those down, there's more, aren't there?
On the other side?
I wonder if I can shoot them down, though.
Wouldn't it be kind of fun?
Oh, can I even... Oh, I can't even reach.
I'm too... I can't look out.
I can't look out.
Stinger missile?
Will that work?
No use.
Don't look at my skirt!
What are you doing?
Oh, because I'm laid down!
Let's try it again.
Oh!
I wish I could target all of them, though.
But I should save these, shouldn't I?
Won't the cameras... be... um...
Won't they be re-put up later on?
And there's, like, a ton of them?
I'm trying to decide which would be better to use.
The chaff?
Probably just the chaff.
We'll save the stinger for future fight.
We'll need the chaff for future fight too.
You get lots of stingers, you do?
No, I tried sniping them already.
Hmm... Revolver Doki makes more sense.
Yeah, I think if we were to replace the models with people...
I think Matara could be Liquid Snake.
I think Doki would have to be Revolver Os a lot.
I was thinking maybe Henya could be Psycho Mantis.
Because it's... I don't know.
I feel like a psychic is in the same leagues as a...
I don't know.
There's a genius, you know?
Revolver Doki... Henya could be Otacon.
That would... Oh!
I guess that works even better, right?
Also... I don't know in the save which ending we're going to get.
I originally played to get the Meryl ending.
I have no idea.
If... So it will be gotcha.
Don't tell me!
Jeremy, if you're still here, don't tell me.
Don't tell me.
I want it to be a surprise.
So...
We will see what happens.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
Oh my god!
Okay, you know what?
There's no way I'm using this...
Look at this!
Look at all of them on the... This is... No.
No!
Okay, yeah.
Using the stinger is totally useless.
There's too many!
How do I throw?
Here we go!
Stinger!
Missile!
Why did they put...
It's almost done.
I'm so excited here.
I'm turning the volume up.
Are you guys ready?
Starts with a Z.
Are you running this mod on actual hardware, Minto?
I just feel like you'd be the person to get a Japanese PS1 to play this.
I'm not gonna lie.
I 100% thought about it, but I did not have time to set it up.
But I did... I did really want to.
Alright, here we go.
Rex!
Take that for sure.
Oh, there's a camera there.
Keep
moving.
Ah!
Not this way!
Move the other way!
Oh, I don't think it goes anymore.
Okay, that's fine.
We'll have to go down there anyway later on.
Hello?
Otacon!
Oh no!
Looks like they've finished getting Metal Gear ready.
How do you know that?
I overheard them talking.
Oh no!
Where are you now?
Right in front of Metal Gear, but it's strange.
What is?
There's nobody here.
No guards.
Nobody patrolling.
It's too quiet.
Maybe because they're all ready.
They said they even input the PAL cards.
No!
What should I do?
All we can do is use the override system that President Baker told you about.
Okay, okay.
But I've only got one of the three keys.
And besides that, like Ocelot said, there's some trick to using the keys.
Leave it to me.
You got some kind of plan?
Well, I'm in the computer room right now.
I'm trying to access Baker's private files.
Baker's files?
Don't you need a password?
Of course, but there are ways.
He's hacking?
Are you a hacker?
Yup, that describes me pretty well.
Does it look like you can get in?
Are you a hacker?
Give it a try.
I'm counting on you.
Oh, don't look up my skirt, please.
Oh, I don't remember where the guards are around here.
They're upstairs, right?
Wow!
Who
keeps calling me?
Snake, it's me again.
Noticon!
How's it going?
Not bad.
I just got past his third security level.
That was fast.
He was a pretty careful guy.
Do you think you'll break in soon?
Why don't you guys just stay on the phone?
I never had a system I couldn't bust into.
Okay.
Keep trying.
Yum.
Alright, here we go.
Don't look.
Stop!
Oh, there's some stuff.
I'll go grab all that.
Famous.
Greetings, Germany.
Second time watching VTuber.
My viewer passed away from Animal.
Money goes towards Save the Frames, Krill, the DARPA Chief, or Bustin.
Can I get a hype?
Hype.
Hype, hype, hype.
Passed away from Animal.
I'm so sorry for your loss.
Oh.
Oh, my gosh, wait.
We haven't seen me kick.
Wow!
Nice.
That's a completely responsible parent.
I am so proud of my boy.
Doesn't he call me here?
Yep.
He did it!
What do you got?
What?
Just as I thought, the nuclear warhead is designed to be fired from the railgun like a projectile.
Okay.
It doesn't use fuel, so it isn't considered a missile.
This is craziness!
That way it can get around all sorts of international treaties.
Uh-oh.
Pretty sneaky.
Yes, but effective.
Effective?
And that's not even the scariest thing about this weapon.
Uh-oh.
I can't wait to hear this.
It's a stealth weapon.
You mean it won't show up on radar?
That's crazy!
The truth is they've been working on a stealth missile since the late 70s.
Uh-oh.
Why weren't they able to develop one until now?
Because of the missile rocket propulsion system, it would be picked up by enemy satellites.
But this toward... towards runner's mitt.
Oh, yeah.
That makes sense.
But unlike a missile, the railgun doesn't burn any propellant, so it can't be detected by any current ballistic missile detection systems.
An invisible nuclear warhead...
That's so scary.
...can be impossible to intercept.
And on top of that, it's got a surface-piercing warhead designed to penetrate hardened underground bases.
Oh, my God.
They just were like, let's take everything by...
This thing could mean the end of the world.
It's the ultimate weapon.
The ultimate weapon.
And from a political point of view, it avoids the problem of nuclear reduction and nuclear inspections.
Colonel, is this true?
Are you listening?
Uh, Colonel?
I'm listening.
Ugh.
If word of this got out, it could delay the signing of the Star III Treaty and cause a huge international incident.
Yeah, it would be nasty.
Nasty.
The United States would be denounced by the UN.
It would be...
It could even bring the President down.
Did you know this, Colonel?
I'm sorry.
Oh, Colonel.
You've changed, Colonel.
I won't make any excuses.
Snake, listen to me.
This new nuclear weapon, it's never actually been tested.
Only simulated.
What if it, like, broke apart the minute, like, they tried to shoot?
Yeah.
That's why they were conducting this exercise.
The... the missile.
They needed to get actual experimental data to back up the simulation.
They don't even know if it works.
What were the results of the exercise?
It looked like it was a nuclear bomb.
It looks like it went better than they hoped for.
It was put together by the...
I can't find the data anywhere on this network.
You'd think the data, as important as that, would be carefully recorded.
It was.
Just don't sit by the exit seat.
President Baker gave me an optical disc with all the test data.
Hello from Scotland.
What?
I hope you prevent World War III and neutralize like a steak.
Do you still have it?
No.
Ocelot took it from me.
Thank you.
The terrorists have replaced the dummy warhead with a real warhead.
Once they input the detonation codes, they should be ready to launch.
So you think they can do it?
Well, the dummy warhead was designed to be identical to the real thing, so I think so.
Ice Monkey is a better person than you?
Did you find out how to override it yet?
Not yet.
It must be in a separate file.
Right now, I'm looking through all of Baker's personal files.
Warheads from Teemu?
Oh, my God.
No, I'm warheads from Teemu.
Okay, so he's like over...
Oh, my God.
There he is.
How can I get his butt?
Gosh, I wish there was first person... first person choosing.
I don't remember what his... what his route is like.
Let's see.
I think he only goes...
Oh, hi!
You don't see me?
This guy gives this guy some glasses.
I could technically maybe go now.
How long does he stay over there?
How long is he over there for?
Nikita for a challenge?
I'm just gonna launch a Nikita missile at this poor dude?
He's over there for a while.
Does he come over here?
I don't think so.
Do it now.
The Nikita missile?
Will it even let me?
No use!
It won't let me.
Wait, what about a stinger though?
No way!
Wait.
You're not coming this way, are you?
Okay, he stops right there.
Hey buddy!
I just saved your life.
I just saved your life, man!
Can they still hear my footsteps if I'm in the box?
Zoom!
Can you snipe them?
Oh, maybe.
Actually, I don't think so, cause I'll lay down and it'll be like, all annoying.
Did he hear me?
Yeah?
I'm kinda busy!
He's just looking to get rich, isn't he?
Arms tech is in much worse financial trouble than I thought.
I know they lost their bid to make the next generation fighter jet.
That plus the reduction in SDI spending...
How's the audio, by the way?
It's kind of hard for me to gauge.
So I'm really sorry if it's kind of off.
Or too loud, or too whatever.
And it looks like we were paying a lot of bribe money to the DARPA chief.
Bribe money, huh?
It's good?
Okay, thank you guys.
And Baker was a big proponent of the nuclear deterrent theory.
I see.
Slightly quiet.
What about this?
This is the override.
Just give me a little bit longer.
I feel like the music is kinda loud, which is why I...
Oh, he's coming back.
We'll stay right here.
Oh.
Just a box.
Wait, where are you going?
No, no you're not.
Get out of the way!
Are you serious right... oh.
Are you serious right now?
Uh...
Which was CQC?
Oh wait.
I'm hidden?
I'm hiding?
Okay, I've entered the PAL codes and disengaged the safety device.
Oh, they're blurry.
Whoa!
Whoa, they're so blurry.
It looks like we'll have to show them that we mean business.
Should I set it for Cherniton, Russia?
No.
There's been a change.
The new target is Lopnor, China.
Why, boss?
Look, he can see my hand!
Come on, Mito, your sleeves!
Mr. Golukovich would really like to see a nuclear bomb dropped on your motherland, right?
Liquid.
But why?
There's nothing there.
Wrong.
It's a nuclear test site.
If we nuke a major population center, the game's over.
Is that solid, Mito?
But a nuclear explosion at the test site can still be concealed from the public.
Meanwhile, Washington will be worried about the retaliatory strike from China.
That'll probably mean top-secret talks between both countries' leaders.
Not top-secret.
And in the process, the President will be forced to divulge the existence of...
Never without being subscribed!
...a new and highly destabilizing nuclear weapon to the Chinese.
What do you think that will do to the U.S.'s reputation?
You don't wanna subscribe to me?
By your side?
And you're not chat, if you're...
You don't have to subscribe if you don't want to.
Big boss's DNA and one billion dollars.
One billion dollars.
That money will be used to cure our genome soldiers as well.
I'm also including the FOXDIE vaccine in our demands.
FOXDIE.
It killed Octopus in the arms tech president.
So it's true that it affects older people first.
Mantis might not have been affected because he wore a mask.
Mask up, everybody.
Wolf wasn't infected either.
Because she's too hot to die.
Oh, never mind.
Something to do with the adrenaline levels.
I could not chat.
Or maybe it's just because this FOXDIE was still experimental and they haven't worked out all the bugs yet.
I was just kidding, but thank you.
In any case, have you heard from your friend, Colonel Sergei Golukovich, at the Spetsnaz?
Oh, Golukovich.
He still has doubts about the ability of Metal Gear.
He said we can talk after Metal Gear's test launch is successful.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't blame him.
He's a very prudent man.
There's nothing to worry about.
The Colonel wants Metal Gear and a new nuclear weapon so bad he can taste it.
If Russia wants to regain its position as a military superpower, they need to reinforce their nuclear arsenal.
They need a nuclear weapon that can't be intercepted.
Metal Gear will allow them to gain first-strike capability over the rest of the world.
Their regular army is in shambles, and they think they can restore their country's military power with nuclear weapons?
Golukovich.
He's no warrior.
He's a politician.
But he's the one who gave us the Hind and most of our other heavy firepower.
He's got over a thousand soldiers under his command.
If we join forces, we could put up quite a resistance here.
Yeah, Rex is pretty cute.
Since Mantis died, the Genome Soldier's brainwashing has started to wear off.
I'm worried about the man's morale.
An alliance with the Russians would boost that as well.
What are you saying?
We're not going anywhere.
We're going to dig in here.
Okay.
You can still escape.
We've got the most powerful weapon ever made, and we're about to ally with Golukovich's forces.
Are you going to fight the whole world?
I like liquid spaghetti hair.
And what's wrong with that?
We can launch a nuclear warhead at any target on this planet.
A nuclear warhead invisible to radar.
And on top of that, this base is full of spare nuclear warheads.
Once we get the DNA and the money, the world will be ours.
We've got everything we need here.
We can eat the nuclear warheads.
What about your promise to Colonel Golukovich?
I'll fly to Japan.
I have no interest in the revival of Mother Russia.
You're not thinking of reviving Big Boss's dream.
From today, call this place Outer Heaven.
Big Boss's dream.
Mito looks at the camera.
You're not worried about the POW being overridden.
Big Boss's dream.
If the code is in it again, it'll be deactivated.
No need to worry.
Wait, that's not me.
We're not both dead.
Does Snake know how the override system works?
That's not me.
You interrogated him, don't you know?
He didn't have any keys on him.
Good.
Then no one can stop Metal Gear now.
By the way, what should we do with that woman?
Want me to kill her?
Oh, wait.
Let her live.
She's Campbell's niece, and Snake cares for her.
Wait, so she's alive?
We'll keep her as our ace in the hole.
Or maybe we don't.
Beryl.
She's alive.
Beep, beep.
The fourth wall is struggling.
Snake, I found Baker's top secret files.
Let's go.
Great job.
How's it going there?
They've finished inputting the PAL codes.
Oh my god.
So how do we deactivate them?
Okay.
You see, the override system that the President was talking about, it can also be used to input the detonation codes.
You see, if you insert the keys when the warhead is active, you deactivate it.
Okay.
And if you insert them when it's inactive, it becomes activated.
And you can only use the keys once.
Okay.
Only once, huh?
Yeah.
You better get started.
We don't have much time.
But it takes three keys, right?
I've only got one of them.
Hold on a minute.
You see, that's the trick.
You already have all three keys.
Whoa.
What are you talking about?
The card key is made of a shape memory alloy.
Whoa.
Shape memory alloy.
Yes.
It's a magic key.
It changes shape at different temperatures.
The key is made out of it.
Wow.
This card key.
Yeah.
What if I just warm it up between my cheeks?
Do you think it'll be hot enough?
The card key changes shape at different temperatures.
So this key is actually three keys in one.
Clever.
Can you see the input terminals in the center of the control room?
I can.
I see them.
Those three laptop terminals are for the emergency input.
Okay.
There should be a symbol on each screen.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Each symbol.
Each symbol corresponds to a different key.
It feels like Pokemon.
Input the keys in order from left to right.
Okay.
The left one's for the room temperature key.
See the symbol?
Yeah.
Next to that goes the low temperature key.
Between the cheeks?
The one on the right is the high temperature key.
Yeah, like the three starters.
Yeah.
Okay.
I got it.
First, I change the shape of the card.
Of course.
And then I input them in order, right?
That's right.
Might be too hot.
All you do is insert the card keys.
We're going to melt the card key.
After you insert the key into the module, a hard drive will pop up.
The hard disk reads the information contained on it.
Once you've finished with all three terminals, the code input process is complete.
But here's the thing.
What are they doing?
You can only use the key three times.
Okay.
It's an emergency system.
It's only meant to be used once.
Wait, so then how have they used it before?
The world is riding on that key, Snake.
Hey, shut up.
Ah!
My key!
God!
Why would you do this to me?
The key fell on the train.
It's dead.
Oh, my God.
Snake!
Who made that sound effect?
This is bulletproof glass.
There's no way in.
I'll enjoy watching you die.
Don't lock me out, Liquid.
Let me into your heart.
Snake, you've got to get that key.
Mint!
You've got to get that key.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Whoa, whoa, wait.
I'm just going to run.
Wait.
Ah!
I'm not going to just run.
Um...
Oh, my God.
Was this from before?
Seriously?
Bye.
Yeah, dummies.
I've got a key to get it.
Please.
Leave me alone.
Is that a mod?
Absolutely.
Look at their minto eyes.
Nothing here.
Wait.
Here it is.
It's doing something.
Pre-order bonus.
This is from the base game.
Yeah.
I've always been there, you guys.
I like how when you look at me from the bottom up, I just look really bald underneath.
Like my head has been shaved.
You know?
Wait.
Wasn't there a way?
Oh, right here.
Here.
There we go.
All right.
Let's go into some acid water.
Water.
I
don't remember where it's at.
Nice.
There's also bombs under here, aren't there?
Wait!
Oh, see, yeah, yeah.
Nice, nice.
How do I get... avoid that?
Okay, nice.
Ration.
Is it over here by...
I can't remember where it's at.
Taking a dip in the forbidden drink.
This is VTuber bathwater.
That's the card?
Are you sure?
Isn't that the card key?
Solid Snake's greatest ally, Matterment.
Are you guys sure?
I think the dot is the card.
But it's...
But it's the Mind Detector!
The card should show up with the Mind Detector.
I'm... scared.
Call Otacon, you're so right.
You're so right.
Otacon, I lost the key!
I'm... I'm a moe, mate.
I dropped it because I'm Dojiko.
You need that key to do it.
Find that key, Snake.
There's no other way.
Otacon!
Call Master.
Find that key.
It fell somewhere in that drainage ditch.
Use your Mind Detector.
Mind Detector.
Yes.
The Mind Detector works just like a metal detector.
The position of the card key should show up on your radar screen.
We found it!
Thanks, Colonel.
Master Miller.
You lost the key?
Hurry up and find it.
They've already entered the detonation code.
Sorry.
The only way to stop that launch is to lock the system by re-inputting the detonation codes.
If you use the Mind Detector, you should be able to find the key.
Even Master knows.
Even if it fell into the drainage ditch.
Whatever you do, find that key.
He's disappointed in me.
I'm sorry, Master.
Loving this phantom snake mod.
Stay based, good girl.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
We... Oh, we got a bomb!
That's not the card!
The card key!
Snake, did you find the key?
No, I found the bomb!
No, it's not here.
Join!
Don't be ridiculous.
You saw it fall into the drainage ditch, didn't you?
Thank you so much.
The drainage ditch.
Thank you.
Isn't there something odd about it?
No.
There are a lot of big rats, though.
That's it, Snake.
A rat must have eaten it.
Now who's being ridiculous?
No, I'm right.
There's no other possibility.
Rats eat all sorts of things.
There's nothing unusual about it.
Why did you call me to tell the...
What?
The rat ate the... the key?
I don't feel like I ever heard this before.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Oi!
Throw it!
Wait, how do I get it out of my...
Oh, there we go.
Oi!
Oh, that was close.
Mine detector!
Hey, rat.
Did you eat the key?
Oh!
No way.
He's literally up there.
Unless he ate a bomb.
Oh my god, stupid rat.
Did you eat a bomb, you stupid rat?
Where'd he go?
Oi.
Little rat!
Where'd you go with the key?
You were here!
Zoom.
What?
Is he... Oh, I found him!
No, no, no, you don't crawl in there!
Oh, shoot.
Oh, he's going around.
I'm watching him.
I'm watching him crawl through the pipes.
Just run.
He's down that way.
Little rat.
Where is he?
Is he down here?
I think he's down here.
Maybe.
Wait.
This is such an awesome angle!
I've never seen this angle before, I don't think.
Oh my gosh, it's so awesome.
Oh, shoot.
The rat is...
Oh, there he is.
I think I keep spooking him.
I don't remember this part at all, to be honest.
Is this from Integral?
Is this like a special Integral thing, or...
I don't remember.
Can we replace the rats with tiny Mintos?
Little rat!
Oh, it's random.
No way.
That's crazy.
Little rat!
You going back this way?
I'll meet you there.
I'm gonna put a bomb.
I'm gonna... I'm gonna blow up this rat.
Wait, he left!
Oh, he left.
It would be funny if the rat turned out to be leading you into a colony of Zanzibar hamsters.
Oh, where did he go?
Stupid guy.
Okay, we need to see where he kind of hangs out, and then like...
Oh, get up.
Get up there.
Oh, you stupid... You stupid...
Where does he even come from here?
I can't even tell.
Has to do with how many alerts you get.
Low equals right.
Really?
Does that mean I'm doing well?
No way.
No way!
The other thing is that it's random, though.
That's so awesome!
I did well enough to get the rat!
Where did he go, though?
Where the hell is he?
Why
didn't he blow up?
Oh,
no, that's my bomb.
I'm an idiot.
Wait, he might blow up now.
What?
I got it!
It's okay, the death happened offscreen.
I'm an idiot, though.
I can't believe I was like, hey, that's my...
Where's the rat?
I can't see him, you guys, but...
It's a ghost rat!
Thank you.
Thank you, Jackal Blaze.
I kinda wanna go get that ration.
I know it's craziness, but...
Nah, it's okay.
I'll go without.
How does it taste?
Yeah, they were giving us a little...
A little sneak... sneak peek of, uh...
Of three.
Guide says under ten alerts is the rat?
There's no way I did that well.
There's no way.
Minto Gaming?
Some heating or cooling pipes you can shoot?
No.
Binary Ghost?
That's actually only for...
That's actually only for... what's it called?
Twin Snakes.
Unfortunately, for this, we have to backtrack.
I wanna get this guy's butt.
Maybe I can get him from when he's right here.
Because if he sees my box, he kicks me over.
Jerk.
Use the stinger?
Yeah, I think I will.
I think I will stinger his face.
Will it kill him though?
Maybe from this close it should, right?
Come on over.
He's gonna die?
Good.
Oh, didn't you say this was a different save?
Yeah, you're so right.
No wonder.
I was like, there's no way I had less than...
than ten.
That's not my fault.
That is the stinger.
That's not my fault!
The stinger missile is broken!
It's broken!
Oh, she's so skilled, she can miss with a locked-off gun.
Well, I guess no Minto gaming.
But Jeremy, thanks for...
I guess, thanks whoever...
I don't know actually who put together the save.
But thanks for gaming so I could see the rat.
Completely forgot.
That's not my save.
That's so funny.
Sigh.
All the guided missiles fall...
It actually is though!
How could I have missed?
There's no way!
I wonder if I could snipe them from maybe down here.
Because...
I don't think I can look up...
Oh, maybe I can.
Where is he though?
Hey mister...
Oh, oh here he comes, here he comes.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god.
Wait, mister?
Mister?
Let's use this...
Cigarettes don't really help...
So much but...
Wait, oh I do have the dice as a pound.
Nevermind.
Just gonna use that.
Yippee!
What did he drop?
Oh.
So...
What's over here?
Nothing here...
Look it!
Rex!
Oh, ain't she a beaut!
Ah, let me in.
Wow!
Look how cool she looks.
Here we go.
Okay.
Pow-key time.
Wait, I have...
The gas mask.
Okay.
Don't really want to get shot at...
By this guy right here.
Okay.
Use the gas mask, please.
Jeremy, stop spamming!
Well, I'm gonna say it real quick.
Hello.
Be cute.
That's all.
I'll use it when I need it.
What about you, Snake?
Is your honor just an empty bubble, too?
I don't know.
Where is it?
What is...
What have you done to me?
Oh, my God.
Wait!
All right.
Where's my pow-key?
Pow-key.
Wait.
Just put it in.
All right.
There we go.
What about the goggles?
I'll check.
Why is my head so tiny?
Pow-code number one confirmed.
Yay!
Awaiting pow-code number two.
Okay.
That takes care of pow-code number one.
Now pow-code number two, freeze the key.
Freeze the key!
Okay.
Oh, come on!
What happened to my thing?
It wasn't over?
Goggles.
Oh my god, it's... Oh, I can't even see anything, though.
It's... Oh, it's so... Oh my god, I can't see anything.
It's the same, though, it looks like.
I'm just gonna run for it.
Oh, it didn't even get me.
Nice.
Is this guy still here?
Is this guy back?
Oh my god.
Oh, wait.
Wrong.
The body armor?
Here, we'll check out... We'll try everything here, right?
It's so funny.
What's the body armor?
Where is it?
Body... I tried... I actually have the body armor.
Wait.
My hair is green now.
But it's not undoing it.
That's so funny.
Wait, so... But now my hair is back to normal.
I've become a skinny legend.
I've become a skinny legend!
Oh my god.
My eyes, please.
Okay.
Anyway.
Slendermint.
There he is.
Do you think I can shoot him again?
From here?
I missed him.
Where'd you go?
Why can't I find anything?
I think I'm getting hungry, so...
Oh, there it is.
Oh my goodness.
Choo-choo.
Oh my god.
Take this as a palm.
Please!
Don't move so jerkily like...
Oh my god, please.
Did he die?
Yay!
He did.
Let's go freeze a key.
I wish the hot one was first.
To be honest.
I wish I could go...
All the way to the hot...
I would rather go to the hot one first, you know?
He got sniped.
Sniped from like...
So close.
Hmm...
Use the cardboard box.
I didn't know he was gonna walk over there though.
Oh my goodness, my skirt.
Oh la la.
Don't look.
How's it gonna be?
Yeah, I wish you could pick which key you did first as well.
Yeah, I don't know.
I just don't feel like going all the way to the hot area.
Oh my god, my skirt.
It's breaking a little bit.
What?
What's wrong with me?
Ah!
I'm missing the front part of my skirt.
Oh my god, my skirt.
This way.
Uh...
No.
We're fine here.
It's the other part.
That's the...
Is this...
Is it fine right here actually?
Um...
Let's get our chaff grenades ready.
Shameless ghost!
It's not me!
I just realized that there's a way to go over there.
Interesting.
Okay.
Let's see.
Let me...
My health is still fine.
All right.
The PAL key.
Oh my god.
Oh, I...
Card key.
PAL key.
I like how the whole thing with the card key is a huge Metal Gear 2 reference.
You know what's funny?
Is in my short, when I was just like...
Metal Gear Solid feels like a remake of Metal Gear 2.
There are people who are just like...
Um...
No.
Metal Gear Solid is its own thing.
And I'm like...
I don't think you realize that just like Metal Gear Solid 2, Metal Gear Solid 1 is also basically a remake.
They took it so literally.
But it is...
But like there's so much...
Yeah.
Like...
Oh.
Not yet.
Um...
There's so much from Metal Gear.
Like...
I don't know.
That they use in Metal Gear Solid.
Like it's the same format.
And everything.
But...
What do I know?
I'm just a ghost here.
They've made the same game three times in a row.
Like actually.
Maybe...
You know...
Oh.
It's good.
Kojima is truly a genius.
You know?
He...
He can make the same game three times and it's fine.
I'm going to use so many trap grenades here.
It's kind of painful.
He keeps getting away with it.
Are you playing as yourself?
Yeah.
I've always been in the game.
You're actually in the game.
I'm in the game!
I love how people are coming in and being like...
Yo!
Go
up.
Go up, please.
The car...
The pal key...
Still good.
I think it's the red one that we will have to worry about more, but...
Hmm.
Where is this guy at?
I don't know where he is... where he stands.
Do you think I can get him from here?
I don't think I can though.
Where is he at?
I think I can only see his little feet from here.
And he's gone.
He's gone anyway.
I'm just gonna run for it.
Run!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You won't see me, right?
Yeah.
We're good.
Don't worry about it.
This one.
Beep, beep.
There we go.
Okay.
What was that noise?
Pal code number two confirmed.
We're gonna save the world, you guys.
We're gonna save the world.
We're gonna stop that nuclear... Oh, it's floating.
Next comes pal number three.
Warm the key.
Alright, Snake.
Cheeks open.
Open up.
Do you think it's...
Do you think it's... there's still a...
What's it called?
An alert?
You think there's still an alert?
You think we're good?
Let's go check it out.
We're good!
We're good.
Okay.
Let's snipe this guy.
Where's my... desert pan?
Oh, if you have a cold?
That's so cute.
Oh, where'd he go?
Hello?
Mister?
Come back.
Oh.
I didn't take this, did I?
Wait, or did I?
You know what?
It's fine.
I'm only gonna have to use it a couple times.
Oh, okay.
Double dose.
I'm just, uh, you know... being cautious.
I'm addicted to the meds.
I need my dizzy pam!
Pam!
Take a dip in the Metal Gear soup.
Wait, does that... no, wait, that doesn't work.
That doesn't work, does it?
I mean, it's like nuclear waste, isn't it?
It should work.
Shouldn't it?
Shouldn't it work?
Oh, I went the wrong way.
Oh, that's fine.
Got some more bullets.
Metal Gear acid.
Give me a spoon, I'll test it.
Alright, this way.
I'm actually curious.
But I don't wanna, like...
Just got here and I got jumpscared by seeing VinceFGS be real?
Holy shit.
I don't think it works.
That's me, baby.
That's me in the game.
That's me killing Vulcan Raven one shot.
I mean, not one shot.
One first try.
Oh, I do that every time.
It'll still work though, right?
Please work.
Okay.
I just threw it down into the ground!
Oh, I ended up...
Alrighty.
Let's go.
Let's go back to...
Oh my god, I forgot there's guys here now!
Oh my god, sorry.
It scared me so much.
Wait, I forgot there's guys here now!
No way.
No, my, my, my, my, my little walk.
My walk in the park.
No!
Okay.
Um...
I have to remember...
Okay.
He doesn't see me.
Oh my god.
Why are there so many guys here?
What the hell?
Which way did they go?
Okay.
I'm not in your way.
I'm not in your...
I was not in your way.
I was so out of your way!
You don't have to be like this to be...
You don't have to be like this to me, man.
Luckily, I was just by the door.
So it all worked out.
I will take this ration.
I will take this one.
Just the becks.
He went out of his way to be in your way.
I know, right?
It doesn't... It's so unfair!
I feel like they pick on me for no reason.
They pick on me.
Hey crows, come here.
I'm gonna punch you.
Come here.
I punched him!
Stream?
It's not on my end.
Wait.
Are we good?
Oh, we're back.
We're back.
Okay.
It scared me.
I was about to type in the chat like, hello?
Hot!
Okay, Campbell.
I'm right here.
Why do they all say, hot?
How does Otacon say it?
What about the blast furnace?
But the problem is, if you go through a cold place on the way back, the card key might change shape.
You need to hurry on the way back.
Okay.
That key is actually an IC card.
It's connector pins and main body are made of a shape memory alloy.
It's designed so that unless it's been changed to the correct shape, it won't be recognized by the PAL code input terminal in the control room.
And the detonation code won't be entered.
Okay.
I'll do my best.
I am going to save though.
Real quick.
What can I do for you, Snake?
Save.
Sorry.
Save and save.
Snake.
Come what come may.
Time and the hour runs through the roughest day.
We're almost out of time, Snake.
I know.
Please hurry.
You're the only one who can stop them from launching that nuke.
I'm going.
I'm going for you.
For you.
For you, girl.
Oh.
Hello?
Snake.
It's about Naomi Hunter.
Faster.
Then you should talk to the colonel.
He's looking into it.
Miller, go shoot in someone.
Turn your monitor off.
Okay.
It's off.
No one else can hear us.
Go ahead.
Sorry.
But I didn't want the colonel to hear.
Okay.
So what's up?
Are you going to whisper sweet nothings into my ear?
I've got a good friend in the Pentagon.
Yeah?
He's the one who told me about it.
Okay.
It looks like the DIA recently developed an IC card.
It's a new type of assassination weapon.
An assassination weapon?
Snake, have you ever heard of something called Fox Dye?
Fox Dye.
No.
Liquid and the others were talking about it.
Yeah.
No.
It's some kind of virus that targets specific people.
I don't know all the details, but what are you trying to say?
Yeah, what are you trying to say, huh?
It's too similar.
What is?
The cause of death.
What's the cause of death?
Didn't the arms tech president and the DARPA chief, I mean, decoy octopus, die of something that looked like a heart attack?
Yeah.
Well, apparently, Fox Dye kills its victims by simulating a heart attack.
What?
No.
You're telling me that Naomi was behind it?
Snake, try to remember.
Did Naomi give you some kind of injection?
Nanomachines.
She was in the business.
She was in the best position to have done it, but I don't know what her motive was.
Does the Colonel know?
Guys, I think I'm in trouble.
I'm not sure.
But he still hasn't questioned her.
Okay.
I'll ask him myself.
I feel the Fox Dye flowing through me.
Colonel, what's new with the Naomi situation?
I just placed Naomi under arrest.
Arrest?
She was sending coded messages towards the Alaskan base.
I didn't want to believe it, but she must be working with the terrorists.
Are you sure?
I'm afraid so.
She's being interrogated now.
Are you sure?
Yeah.
Get her ass.
What kind of interrogation?
Well, I'd like to avoid the rough stuff, but we don't even have any...
Punch her.
Call me if you find out anything.
Cut off her tongue.
So it's true, isn't it?
Naomi...
Wait.
Then she can't tell us anything.
I can't believe it.
That means the Fox Dye vaccine must be around somewhere.
Somewhere.
Listen, I've got bigger things to worry about.
But, Snake, you might be infected too, you know?
All I can do...
I think I'm fine.
...is leave it up to the Colonel.
I'm probably fine.
I'm probably okay.
I'm curious.
How fast do I have to go from the hot area to the cold... to the... like... you know, like...
Oh, look at that.
Carrier, boy.
I think there's a bomb over there, right?
And then there's...
Ah!
What?
I'm in here!
Are you kidding me?
I haven't even moved.
I'm going to...
I'm going to blow this thing up.
Take it out!
Okay.
If I'm really careful...
Oh, come on.
I don't even need it.
There was nothing else in here, though, right?
Okay, good.
All righty.
To the heat.
Stop taking injections from random women.
She was...
She was sexy.
The game gives you plenty of time.
Okay, cool.
And we're back!
We got all...
Look at the deep darkness.
It's pretty spooky down there.
She was okay.
Dang.
PP Paladin has some high standards.
I think Naomi is quite attractive.
It's just her personality that really makes it...
Just really ruins it, you know?
Otherwise, I think she's okay.
She's a... fine looking gal.
It's just... when she opens her mouth, I'm like...
Okay.
You can stop now.
That's all.
Mei Ling is so gorgeous.
Mei Ling is perfect.
Nothing can... I'm not saying... it's not like... you know...
I'm saying Mei Ling is prettier than...
Than... I'm not saying Naomi is prettier than Mei Ling or anything.
I'm just saying that...
I'm just saying...
That Naomi is good looking.
But Mei Ling is definitely, you know...
Can I go in here?
Alright, we're just gonna chill in here for now.
If I get caught by the steam...
If I get... If I walk into the steam, that surely should heat it up more.
I see Naomi and... I've seen the Mei Ling 3D model, but actually I don't think I've seen the Naomi one.
Technically not wrong.
Put your hands in the steam.
Look, there's an item there.
It's probably more bullets that I don't need.
Is that solid mint?
Mei...
I'm gonna let it... I'm gonna let it simmer a little bit more.
I can fix her.
Just a little bit more.
It's gotta be peak... It's gotta be peak.
Top tip top red shape.
Call Master Miller.
What's he gonna say to me?
So Naomi's a spy, just like I thought.
Campbell is hiding something too.
Yeah.
But that's okay.
Fox dye is a virus, a biological weapon.
There must be a vaccine.
We can worry about getting that later, Snake.
But right now, you've got to focus on re-inputting those detonation codes.
I mean...
He seems really... You're kinda... You seem a little desperate there.
I'm in.
The key changed shape.
Hurry to the control room.
That's the last key.
Master, I've never heard you so excited.
I was gonna say, he seems really excited.
Master?
The key changed shape.
Hurry to the control room.
That's the last key.
Mr. Miller.
Are you in the boiler room?
Those pipes are really old.
Once in a while, they blow out steam, so be careful.
I've always been careful.
Call this, once in a while.
Snake is so sassy.
Watch out for the steam.
It's dangerous.
Use your first person view to see when the steam is coming out.
And then avoid it.
I love it.
Yeah.
I like Asana now and then, but this is too much.
I love these codec calls.
Alright, I think we're good now.
Wait, what's that?
Is that a rat over there?
Wait, what are the red dots?
Oh no, those are people.
Right?
No, they're not.
What am I seeing?
Anyway, let's just leave.
Okay.
Run, run, run.
Wait, if I put the PAL key away, it's better, right?
Technically, I think.
I gotta stuff it in my pants.
Metaphorical rats.
What does that mean?
Oh no, it's all the nuclear waste here.
They're basically just rat people.
Neither true rat or true person.
They are both.
What pants?
You know how girls will keep stuff in their bras?
Like money and stuff?
I've never done that before because I think...
Oh my god.
I'm in a hurry, man!
I'm just gonna run for it.
Perfect.
Let's go.
It's so gross.
People will like...
I've worked retail where like some lady will pull out a $10 bill from her bra and it's literally damp.
It's so gross.
It's so nasty.
Because it falls straight through.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
If you wear a bra, it's not gonna fall out.
Gosh, you guys.
Oh my god.
Payblade.
Ladder rip.
Snake,
can you hear me?
Naomi.
It's Naomi.
Naomi?
What the hell?
I know that British millennial.
Camp Millennials are busy right now.
I'm on a different codec.
Naomi, is what the Colonel says true?
Yes, but not everything I said was a lie.
Who are you?
I don't know myself.
I don't know my real name or even what my parents looked like.
I bought all my identification.
But my reason for getting into genetics was true.
Because you want to know yourself, right?
That's right.
I want to know where I came from.
My age, my race, anything.
You're white.
And British.
I was found in Rhodesia sometime in the 80s.
A dirty little orphan.
Rhodesia?
What's now known as Zimbabwe?
Yes.
Rhodesia was owned by England until 1965 and there were lots of Indian laborers around.
That's probably where I got my skin color from, but I'm not even sure about that.
See, even she says it.
Naomi, you're too worried about the past.
Isn't it enough to understand who you are now?
Understand who I am now?
Why should I?
No one else tries to understand me.
I love this track.
I was alone for so long.
Until I met my big brother.
And him.
Him?
Your big brother.
Yes.
Frank Jaeger.
What?
He was a young soldier.
Frank Jaeger!
Wait a second.
I was half dead from starvation.
Jaeger?
He shared his rations with me.
Hunter!
Yes.
Frank Jaeger.
The man who you destroyed was my brother and my only family.
No.
Gray Fox?
Oh my god!
We survived that hill together, Frank and I.
Jaeger is...
He protected me.
...Hunter in German!
It's my one connection.
I never made the connection!
The only connection I have to my past.
And he brought you back to America.
No.
I was in Mozambique when he came.
Who is he?
You mean Big Boss?
Yes.
He brought us to this land of freedom.
This America.
Then he and my brother went back to Africa to continue the war.
Thank you.
And that's when it happened.
You killed my benefactor and sent my brother home a cripple.
I vowed revenge and joined Foxhound.
But...
I knew it was my best chance to meet you and I prayed for the day that I would.
I was part of Foxhound.
Why would you join Foxhound?
May I ask your prayers answered?
Yes.
I waited two long years.
Shut up Naomi.
Is that all you cared about?
Yes.
I tried.
What?
Two years.
You were all I thought about for too long...
Gosh, everyone's so obsessed with me!
Just like sniperwolf!
Just like Naomi!
Everybody's obsessed with the legend.
...Not exactly.
I was partly wrong about you as well.
Rent-free.
Hunter has English for Jaeger?
I think he just came here to fight you.
I wasn't sure before, but now I think I understand.
A final battle with you.
That's all he lives for.
I'm sure of it.
Fox.
No.
Gray Fox.
Naomi, tell me something.
About Fox Dye?
Fox Dye is a type of retrovirus that targets and kills only specific people.
That's crazy.
First, it infects the macrophages in the victim's body.
Fox Dye contains smart enzymes created through protein engineering.
I mean, I know this is a game, but still.
So retro.
Those enzymes recognize the target's DNA?
Right.
They respond by becoming active and using the macrophages as they begin creating TNF Epsilon.
Hello, Miko.
Hello!
It's a type of cytokine, a peptide which causes cells to die.
The TNF Epsilon is carried along the bloodstream to the heart...
Yawn, yawn, nerd talk.
...where they attach to the TNF receptors in the heart cells.
Come on, Naomi.
Pick it up.
...they cause a heart attack.
The heart cells suffer a shock and undergo an extreme apoptosis.
Then, the victim dies.
Apoptosis?
You mean the heart cells commit suicide?
Naomi's a...
What?
Naomi's a brocon.
You must have programmed that thing to kill me, too.
Right?
Do I still have time?
Naomi, I don't blame you for wanting me dead, but I can't go yet.
I still have a job to do.
You dumb... What about... What's the vaccine, though?
You know, like...
Listen, Snake...
She just creates this thing and then doesn't make a vaccine for it?
I'm not the one who made the decision to use FOXDIE.
You weren't.
You were injected with FOXDIE as a part of this operation.
I just wanted to let you know that.
No, that's not the whole truth.
Come on.
Naomi, you compulsive liar, you!
Snake just...
The real thing I wanted to tell you was...
Huh?
Snake, I...
You've fallen in love with me.
Snake!
Naomi!
Colonel!
I can't allow Naomi to make any more unauthorized transmissions.
What?
Naomi's been removed from this operation.
What happened to Naomi?
What did she mean when she said that FOXDIE was a part of this operation?
Colonel, let me talk to her.
I won't.
She's under arrest.
Colonel!
You double-crossed me.
Snake, there's no time for that.
Right now, your job is to stop Metal Gear.
Colonel is so slimy in this game.
He's so...
I was trying to grab him.
He's so slimy in this game.
I hate it.
Alright, we gotta try and get through here, you guys.
We gotta try and get through here.
Without getting detected.
I'm nervous.
Yeah, back to card time.
Okay.
Just run.
Nice.
Thank you.
Okay.
Chaff grenade.
Nice.
How's our key looking?
It's quite red.
For now.
Damn.
Oh, I love that angle.
I love the angles that show you how massive Rex is.
It's so fun.
Mint tomato.
We'll need those later, you guys.
Oh, wrong way.
Wrong way.
We'll need them later.
It's critical.
Peter O'clock virus.
Stop!
Alright.
Run, run, run!
Alright, let's kill this guy.
Maybe?
Maybe I shouldn't kill him.
I think actually...
Wait, where is he?
No, he's not in back.
I think we can just...
Go through.
Alright.
Our... Our... Our...
Our code is still good?
Okay.
Nice and nice too.
Let's...
Hide from...
Oh my goodness.
Please.
There we go.
Oh my god.
And then...
I think I can just...
Howl key it up.
There we go!
Yippee!
They don't even need the chaff.
Howl code number three.
Confirm...
Yay, we saved the world!
Howl code entry.
Confirm...
Yippee!
Detonation code.
Activated.
No.
Why?
No!
I deactivated it!
Thank you, snake.
Now it's your turn.
Help me.
I need...
How could you?
I let the colonel double-cross you, but how could you double-cross me, too?
Gosh...
The fact that Snake has no idea what's going on this entire game...
It's just so sad.
How could you?
No!
In other words, we weren't able to launch the nuclear device and we were all getting a little worried.
Without the threat of a nuclear strike, our demands would never be met.
What do you mean?
Without the detonation codes, we had to find some other way.
That's when we decided you might prove useful, Snake.
What?
First, I thought we might get the information from you, Snake.
So I had Decoy Octopus disguise himself as the DARPA chief.
Unfortunately, Octopus didn't survive the encounter.
Thanks to FOXDOT.
You mean you had this planned from the beginning?
Just to get me to input the detonation code?
You didn't think you made it this far by yourself, did you?
What a jerk.
Where the hell are you?
In any case, the launch preparations are complete.
Once the world glimpses the power of this weapon, the White House will have no choice but to surrender the FOXDOT vaccine to me.
Their ace in the hole is useless now.
No!
But the Pentagon's plan to use you was already successful in the torture room.
Stop laughing!
You're the only one who doesn't know.
Thank you for the $50,000.
Thank you.
Fool.
Who are you anyway?
I'll tell you everything you want to know.
Yes, yes, yes.
Here we go.
If you come where I am, that is.
Where are you?
Very close by.
Snake, that's not Master Miller.
No shit.
Campbell, you're too late.
Oh my god, the voice change is so great.
Master Miller's body was just discovered at his home.
He's been dead for at least three days.
What?
I didn't know because my codec link with Master was cut off.
You don't confirm these things, Colonel.
But Maylene said his transmission signal was coming from inside the base.
Oh my god.
So who is it?
Snake, you've been talking to...
Oh my god.
Me, dear brother.
Yeah!
Liquid, how the...
You've served your purpose.
You may die now.
No!
Oh my god.
Yes!
Otacon!
Snake, that's bulletproof glass.
You can't break it with an ordinary weapon.
Too sexy for my sunglasses, brother.
Can you open the security lock here?
Otacon, please.
I'll try.
Just hold on for a minute.
Okay.
I don't have a minute.
Oh wow, for Cousin Hero Miller.
Snake, Imerit will be able to open the door.
Just trust him and hang on.
Okay.
I don't trust you though.
Master!
Why is my head so small?
Oh, there's rations in here.
I look like a bean.
Like a pea head.
Snake, I'm opening the door.
Thanks, Otacon!
Yippee!
Oh, I gave you another ration even.
I'm just like, hey.
You're not feeling so well?
Oh my god.
It's actually maybe one of my favorite parts of the game.
I'm not gonna lie.
Do you guys mind if I can get some food before the Rex fight?
So I can eat while Liquid is doing his little monologuing.
So I'm gonna go grab some food real quick.
I'll be fast.
I don't have to heal.
I'll be right back.
Give me like just a few minutes.
Back,
I'm back, I'm back.
Sorry about that.
Alright, hold on.
I have to move a little bit of stuff.
Okay, alright.
Don't spill it.
Okay.
Here we go.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you guys.
Alright, we ready for...
Let's go.
Time for me to eat.
Oh.
Wow, that's a whole lot of Liquid.
Really, you just baited me so much.
Oh, I'm still gone fishing.
There we go.
Dang, look at his abs.
This guy never has a shirt on.
It's Alaska.
What are you showing off for?
Liquid.
Snake.
Did you like my sunglasses?
Whoa.
You point a weapon at your own brother?
Why did you disguise yourself as master?
So I could manipulate you more easily.
And you performed quite well, I must say.
Although, the boy is a little bit of a pain in the ass.
The boys at the Pentagon are probably saying the same thing.
What the hell are you talking about?
Following orders blindly with no questions asked.
You've lost your warrior's pride and become nothing more than a palm snake.
What?
Get called out.
Stopping the nuclear launch, rescuing the hostages.
It was all just a diversion.
A diversion?
The Pentagon only needed for you to come into contact with us.
That's what killed the arms tech president and decoy octopus.
Snakes look good in that little eyes.
You don't mean.
That's right.
You were sent here to kill us so they could retrieve metal gear undamaged, along with the bodies of the Genome soldiers.
From the beginning, the Pentagon was just using you as a vector to spread fox dye.
Fox dye?
It can't be.
Are you telling me Naomi was working with the Pentagon?
They thought she was.
But it seems that Dr. Naomi Hunter couldn't be controlled so easily.
Everybody is a double crosser.
We've got a spy working in the Pentagon.
He reported that Dr. Hunter altered Fox Dye's program just before the operation.
But no one knows how or why.
Because she's crazy.
Maybe they arrested her so they could find out the answer to that.
No doubt.
But I had no idea she was motivated by such petty revenge.
We still don't know what changes she made to Fox Dye's program.
He's so disappointed.
Oh well, it doesn't matter.
I've already added the Fox Dye vaccine to my list of White House demands.
There's a vaccine.
There must be.
But if she changed it, then...
But that woman is the only one who really knows.
If she changed it, then it doesn't, you know...
Anyway, it might prove to be unnecessary.
Why's that?
You were successful in coming into contact with all of us.
So we must have all been exposed to the virus.
It's true that the Armstech president and Decoy Octopus were killed by Fox Dye.
But Ocelot, myself, and you, the carrier, were apparently unaffected.
A bug in the virus's programming?
Could be.
In any case, if it doesn't kill you, then I'm not worried either.
After all, our genetic code is identical.
So it's true.
You and I are...
Yes, twins.
But we're not ordinary twins.
We're twins linked by cursed genes.
Genes?
Les enfants terribles.
You got all the old man's dominant genes.
I got the flawed recessive genes.
Everything was done so that you would be the greatest of his children.
I got the acid wash genes.
The only reason I exist is so they could create you.
I was the favorite, huh?
That's right.
I'm just the leftovers of what they used to make you.
Can you understand what it's like to know that your garbage...
...has changed since the day you were born?
But...
I'm the one father chose.
So that's why you're so obsessed with Big Boss.
Some warped kind of love.
Love?
It's hate!
He always told me I was inferior.
And now I'll have my revenge!
Big Boss!
I can't imagine him saying that, you know?
You killed our father with your own hands!
I just can't imagine him being like, Hey, inferior brother!
Over there!
Now I'll finish the work that father began!
I will surpass him!
I will destroy him!
You're just like Naomi.
Well, I'm not like you!
I'm like you!
I'm proud of the destiny that is encoded into my fairy genes!
Uh-oh.
Is it time?
It's close to time.
Snake!
Your blood will be the first to be spilled by this glorious new weapon!
Like you?
No!
Consider it an honor!
A gift from your brother!
Now I'll show you the power of the weapon that will lead us in the 21st century!
Okay, I got my controller.
I put away my food.
It's moving.
I wonder how I'm gonna do on the fist fight.
Like this!
How do I stop it?
Ta-da!
Here we go.
Ow!
I look so awesome!
Guys, I'm getting a stomachache already.
Immediately, body armor.
Immediately, trap grenades.
Run!
What
the hell?
Oh my god!
No!
What are you doing?
Okay, hold on.
That's not what I meant to do.
I meant to call Auto-Gun.
What do I do?
What?
Stop!
Okay.
Naked eyes.
His special eyes.
Yeah!
Alright!
Keyboard duck.
Stinger missile!
I already threw the chat.
The Ray Dome.
Oh, look at that.
Ah!
The Ray Dome.
As much as I hate to acknowledge MGS5, the implication is that it's how Liquid felt rather than the reality.
It's a good point.
Character flaw.
I think.
I guess so.
I owe you one, Otacon.
Okay.
I will save.
I know it's probably pointless.
Snake, there's nothing I can do to help you.
All I can do is cheer you on.
I know it's kind of pointless, but I am going to save.
We'll save because, you know, what if something crashes, right?
Okay.
Don't give up.
Don't give up!
I'm scared.
I'm scared!
Guys!
Guys, it's not good!
Not a good start!
Not good start!
Okay.
Stinger.
Explode, please!
Did I even throw it?
I don't think I threw the chat grenade.
Gosh.
There we go.
Okay, I'm
going to really concentrate on this part.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh god, oh god.
Please!
My body armor, I gotta re-equip it.
This thing can still seek me out so easily.
Snake!
We have Zanzibar counter one!
We haven't even hit Zanzibar!
It's okay, we started off really bad, so...
Can I skip this part?
Okay, there we go.
Alright.
Oh god,
I don't have anything on.
Oh,
I did a stun grenade.
I'm such an idiot.
Run!
Oh my god.
Sorry,
I'm just concentrating really much.
The time, actually.
Even the time.
Oh no, here it comes.
Snake!
Rip it off!
Gray Fox!
He was deep-thrown!
He's a terrible snake.
You haven't aged well.
I'll send you back to hell!
Gray Fox!
Fox, why?
What do you want from me?
I'm a prisoner of death.
Only you can free me.
Fox, stay out of this.
What about Naomi?
She's hell-bent on taking revenge for you.
Naomi?
You're the only one who can stop her.
I can.
Why?
Because I'm the one who killed her parents.
I was young then, and couldn't bring myself to kill her, too.
I felt so.
I raised her like she was my own blood to soothe my guilty conscience.
Even now, she thinks of me as her brother.
What?
From the outside, we might have seemed like a happy brother and sister.
But every time I looked at her, I saw her parents' eyes staring back at me.
Tell her for me.
Tell her that I was the one who did it.
I'll tell her.
I'll definitely tell her.
We're just about out of time.
Here's a final present from Deep Throat.
Oh, yeah.
I'll stop it from moving.
Fox!
No!
Who
is that exoskeleton of yours?
Snake!
Are you just going to sit by and watch him die?
Oh, boy.
Gornet Fox is more dangerous than a jackal.
Yeah!
Destroyed the ray dome.
No, I can't do it.
I can't do it.
Impressive!
You are indeed worthy of the codename Fox.
I can't do it.
But now you're finished!
No!
Fire the stinger!
Fox!
Can you really shoot?
You'll kill him too!
Oh.
Now!
I
was taken from the battle.
Neither truly alive nor truly dead.
I can't do it.
In a world of light.
Just put him out.
Just do it.
But it's no good.
It's no good.
I can't do it.
Soon it will finally end.
No, I can't do it.
After Zanzibar...
Die!
I was...
No!
We're not tools of the government or anyone else.
I love this part.
Fighting was the only thing.
The only thing I was good at.
But at least I always fought for what I believed in.
Speak.
Farewell.
No.
Foolish man.
Death.
And it found him.
You see?
You can't protect anyone.
Not even yourself.
Die!
Okay.
Hey, hey, hey.
Chill, chill, chill, chill, man.
Chill, chill, chill.
All right.
Hold on.
I'm hyping myself up.
Mentally.
No.
Oh, those hit.
Can I get him from here?
Am I too close?
Oh.
Ah.
Shit.
I'm too close.
Ah.
Shit.
I didn't miss.
I didn't make it.
Okay.
Oh.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Sorry.
I'm getting lost in the sauce a little bit, you guys.
I'm getting lost in the sauce a little bit.
Okay.
We just got to do the same thing.
But...
Oh my God.
You're too close?
Ah.
Shit, shit, shit, shit, shit.
I thought I had the stun grenades open.
These do work, right?
Like...
Okay.
All right.
Stop.
You're not supposed to see me.
The
whole stinger to the face.
It's crazy.
Shouldn't it be the chaff?
No.
It's not the chaff because...
Because...
I don't know.
It's because the ray doman's done.
Now he's looking with his eyes.
Give
me more rushes.
Why
doesn't it work as well?
Like the chaff is like for sure to work, but this like doesn't.
I just can't get the timing of it right.
Ah.
Chill out.
You jerk.
Oh.
No.
Oh shit.
I'm going to die.
I'm going to...
Oh.
Ah.
This is not it.
Oh.
Oh man.
Ah.
It was close though.
Snake.
What happened?
Oh.
It was close.
Snake.
Ah.
Why
are his eyes so much better like than... than... when he's using the... the VR, huh?
That's my question.
Why do his eyes work...
Oh.
Hello?
Oh my god.
I just put down a C4.
I'm such an idiot.
I thought...
Wait.
Did I even throw this?
Why do his eyes work better?
When he's...
When he's eye...
He was inside the thing.
180 IQ.
I guess so.
Oh
my god.
I just realized.
Question.
Ah!
Ouchie ouch ouch ouch ouch ouch ouch ouch ouch.
Ouchie ouch ouch ouch.
Um.
Like this part, I can pretty much get down easy.
Ouchie ouch.
I say that.
I should...
Hold on.
Um.
As soon as I shoot this...
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna put on the body armor.
I'm...
Or I'm gonna heal.
Put on the body armor instead.
Did I...
Should I throw another shaft?
If not, it's just...
I'm just gonna throw another one just in case.
Okay.
Let's do it.
Yeah.
Respect people's boundaries.
Exactly.
Try getting behind him in phase two.
Does that actually work?
Try.
Oh wait.
I'm gonna skip this.
I'm sorry.
Cause this is the...
In front of you.
No accident.
An undying.
Shadow.
In a world of...
This phase two always gets me, man.
Look at him up there in the corner.
Ugh.
I haven't even made a single hit.
You guys.
How
do I get to him?
Oh no.
How do I get to him?
Hey.
Turn around, idiot.
Don't
look for me.
I'm a lost cause.
Don't look for me.
No.
Thank you guys!
I remember.
Oh, shoot.
Don't look for me.
Why does he just stand there?
When you think of it that way, it's so much easier.
You're gonna crush me!
Wait, I think I'm facing... oh no, I'm facing the right way.
Don't see me, don't see me, don't see me.
Yeah, you don't know.
Don't get crushed, don't get crushed, Snake.
Go between his legs.
He's antsy.
He is antsy.
Come
on, come on.
Right here.
I'm gonna try it.
Nice!
Well,
he lost track of me anyway.
What a dummy.
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
Okay, maybe I can get it in, maybe I can get it in.
You're too close, you're too much on me, okay?
You're too obsessed with me.
I'm telling you.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Could you not do that?
Sir, stun gun.
Stun gun!
Stun... gun!
Stop walking backwards.
Okay, I'm turning it.
Oh my god, don't blow it up, don't blow it up, don't blow it up.
Don't blow it up.
Stop.
Stop, Liquid, stop.
Stop, Liquid, you're gonna blow it up.
Stop, I'm right here, right here.
Please.
Please, Liquid, please.
You're being too erratic.
You're scaring me, you're scaring me.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Ouch.
Ouchy, ouchy.
It's okay.
Oh, gosh.
Wait, maybe it's not okay.
No, you don't.
You don't see me.
I'm a ghost!
I'll crush you into dust.
How could she miss?
Come grab me, brother.
Oh, panties.
No!
Oh my god.
How are you still alive?
How?
You've taken so many...
So many stinger missiles to the butt.
I was gonna say to the face, but I literally went underneath you.
Wow, the stack.
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
What do you mean, like, as usual?
You don't know me.
Okay, good.
I can eat some more.
Guys, I got it in three tries.
Fighting.
What are you really after?
A world where warriors like us are honored as we once were?
The length of this stream is how long it used to take me.
Actually, it should be.
That was Big Boss's fantasy.
It was his dying wish.
Oh, wait.
Thank you for the fantasy.
When he was young, during the Cold War, the world needed men like us.
We were valued then.
We were desired.
But things, oh, are different now.
I'm still desired.
What are you talking about?
We're hypocrites running the world.
War isn't what it used to be.
War has changed.
We are losing our place in a world that no longer needs us.
A world that now spurs our very existence.
Big Chunkus, do you know Big Chunkus?
You should know that as well as I do.
After I launch this weapon and get our billion dollars, we'll be able to bring chaos and honor back to this world.
You think they'd stop making these metal gear machines after a show time and time again?
One man.
Or one maid can take them out.
All right.
Conflict will breed conflict.
New hatred will arise.
Then, we'll steadily expand our sphere of influence.
But as long as there are people, there will always be war.
But the problem is balance.
Father knew what type of a balance was best.
Is that the only reason?
Isn't it reason enough for warriors such as us?
I don't want that kind of world.
You lie.
So why are you here then?
Why do you continue to follow your orders while your superiors betray you?
Why did you come here?
Well, I'll tell you then.
You enjoy the killing.
What?
Are you denying it?
Haven't you already killed most of my comrades?
I'm sorry, I can't get the Twin Snakes version out of my head.
When he's like, up in your face about it.
I watched your face when you did it.
It was filled with the joy...
of battle.
You're wrong.
There's a killer inside you.
You don't have to deny it.
We were created to be that way.
Created?
Let's not applause yet though, I still have one more battle.
Les Enfants Terribles.
The Terrible Children.
That's what the project was called.
It started in the 1970s.
Their plan was to artificially create the most powerful soldier possible.
The person that they chose as the model was the man known then as the greatest living soldier in the world.
Big Boss.
Her father was wounded in combat and already in a coma when they brought him in.
So they created us from his cells.
With a combination of 20th century analog cloning and the Super Baby Man.
Super Baby Man.
They fertilized an egg with one of father's cells.
I like how even Snake is just like Super Baby Man.
Then they transferred the clones to someone's uterus and later intentionally aborted six of the fetuses to encourage strong fetal growth.
Yeah!
Eat the fetus!
Eat each other in the womb!
Sorry.
I looked like I was going through the Super Baby Method.
Stop!
Before the day we were even born.
So it was you and I.
Two fertilized eggs with exactly the same DNA.
Minto, close your legs!
But they weren't finished yet.
They used me as a guinea pig.
To create a phenotype in which all of the dominant genes were expressed.
To create you.
I got all of the recessive genes.
Dot dot dot.
You took everything from me before I was even born.
Super Baby Minto.
Super Baby.
You and I aren't his only children.
What?
The Genome Soldiers.
They too are his progeny.
Carrying on his genetic legacy.
Oh my god.
Avert your eyes.
Freak Phantom, stop!
With the completion of the Human Genome Project, the mysteries of humanity were laid bare.
Sometimes the sound, the background noise stops, and sometimes it comes back.
Real footage.
Thanks to Father's DNA, they were able to identify more than 66...
That's my dad!
60 soldier genes responsible for everything from strategic thinking to the proverbial killer instinct.
Yeah!
Those soldier genes were transplanted into the members of the next generation's special forces.
Oh, that's my dad!
There's Naomi!
That's how they became the Genome Soldiers.
Oh.
That's right.
Time for the Super Babies part.
The Genome Soldiers that you've been killing are our brothers.
Oh my god.
That's my dad!
With the same genes as ours.
The Genome Soldiers.
That's right.
They are our brothers.
I'm so embarrassed.
Stop looking at my spread legs.
Created artificially through the alignment of nucleotides to mimic our father's genes.
They too are the product of numerous sacrifices.
Sacrifice?
Human experiments.
I can't!
1991.
The Gulf War.
I can't pay attention at all.
The military secretly injected soldiers with the soldier genes.
Oh my god, it's too funny.
The Gulf War.
The Gulf War syndrome that hundreds of thousands of returning soldiers complained about was a side effect of it.
Oh.
That's me.
Everyone knows that the Gulf War syndrome was caused by exposure to depleted uranium used in the anti-tank rounds.
Super Babies.
Babies.
Baby juice.
That was just a cover story issued by the Pentagon.
Whoa.
First they tried to say it was post-traumatic stress disorder.
Look how fast he's going.
Then chemical or biological weapons.
The poison gas detection units.
Starting your dominance on me.
And the anti-serine injections.
They were all just a cover-up of the secret genetic experiments.
Money for pants.
So then, the so-called Gulf War Babies that have been reported by Gulf War veterans are...
Yes.
Us.
They too are...
The brothers.
Our brothers and sisters.
So the genome soldiers mean that the experiments were a success?
Success?
Don't be a fool.
They're a complete failure.
We are on the verge of extinction.
Oh my god.
No.
But you have so many genome soldiers here.
Have you ever heard of the asymmetry theory?
Huh?
Nature tends to favor asymmetry.
Those species which have gone extinct all show signs of symmetry.
The genome soldiers suffer from the same problem.
Oh my god.
This angle.
I can't.
So do I.
As do you.
Oh my god.
Minto.
That's right.
We are all on the verge of extinction.
We are on the verge of death at the genetic level.
We don't know when or what type of disease will occur.
That's why we need the old man's genetic information.
You want Big Boss's DNA so you can save your family?
It's very touching.
In nature, family members don't mate with each other and yet they help each other to survive.
Do you know why?
I think sometimes they mate with each other.
It increases the chance that their genes will be passed on to a new generation.
Altruism among blood relatives is a response to natural selection.
It doesn't stop me.
It's the giant, like, horn coming out of... that's, like, censoring everything.
Jeans!
Don't take a shot every time he says jeans, you guys.
You'll die.
In order to break the curse of my heritage.
At least her shirt is still on.
And to do that, first, I will kill you.
No!
Okay.
Look behind you.
Merle!
Is she alive?
I'm not sure.
She was alive.
She was alive a few hours ago.
Oh, boy.
Poor girl kept calling your name.
Oh, no.
Merle.
Stupid woman.
Falling in love with a man who doesn't even have a name.
I have a name.
No, we have no past.
No future.
And even if we did, it wouldn't be truly ours.
You and I are just copies of our father, Big Boss.
Let Merle go.
As soon as we've finished our business.
We're almost out of time.
We're talking about foxtie.
Whoa.
It seems now that the Pentagon knows that Metal Gear is destroyed.
That was so fast.
They've arrived at a decision.
How do they know that Metal Gear is destroyed?
Also, I'm huge next to him.
Look at this.
If you want the details, why don't you ask your precious Colonel Campbell?
I look like...
I look like I'm like...
Colonel, can you hear me?
Yes.
I'm listening.
What is the Pentagon trying to do?
I'm so mad.
Colonel, answer me.
The Secretary of Defense has taken over active control of this operation.
He's on his way there by now.
A wax.
What for?
To bomb the place.
No.
What?
Not only that.
B-2 bombers just lifted off from Galena Air Force Base.
Why didn't you stop though?
They're carrying B-61-13 surface piercing tactical nuclear bombs.
A wax.
Metal gear is destroyed.
Tell the Secretary of Defense.
The Secretary of Defense heard that Naomi double-crossed us and he's worried about Fox dying.
Will Peter Saul drinking him?
Now that there's no more danger of a nuclear strike from Metal Gear.
He's going to do whatever he wants.
Okay, I trust you.
Not anymore.
Okay.
It's okay, Snake.
The truth is, Foxhound was already the subject of an undercover investigation.
Meryl was transferred to this base just before the terrorist attack as a way of manipulating me.
Okay, I believe you.
Those bastards.
I'm sorry.
They forced me to cooperate in exchange for her life.
You better get out of there, Snake.
Are you sure?
It'll be bad for you.
They forced you, Colonel?
You could have told me at any time.
It's the least I can do for you.
After all the lies.
Colonel.
I'm ordering them to cancel the bombing run.
Cancel!
After that, there's no turning back.
What are you doing?
Colonel!
Uh-oh.
Snake!
Mei-Ling, what happened to the Colonel?
I don't believe it.
What happened?
Snake, the Colonel!
Roy Campbell has been relieved of duty.
She grew a beard!
This is the Secretary of Defense.
Jim, how...
We'll put the Colonel back on.
He's been placed under arrest.
For leaking top secret information.
Abraham Lincoln.
And for the crime of high treason.
Ridiculous.
Yes, he's a ridiculous man.
Oh, I can't wait for that Metal Gear guy.
Ridiculous man.
He truly believed the names in command of this operation.
Hot Cold Man.
Jim House Man.
Real Ridiculous Man.
There won't be a speck of evidence left.
I'm sure the President would want the same thing.
The President ordered this?
The President is a busy man.
Die hard Man.
Running Man.
BoJack Horseman.
Smart.
Don't compliment him.
The scientists, the Genome Army.
Everyone...
Donald.
He's thinking of the scientists.
The DARPA chief is already dead.
Who could you be thinking of?
So you didn't mean to kill the DARPA chief after all.
The house is in place.
Can't be under house arrest.
See ya!
I hate how mean everybody is to them.
You can't be allowed to live.
Well, the bombs will be dropping soon and you two have a lot of catching up to do.
They're so mean.
Farewell.
It's not like they asked to be born like this.
They're so mean.
There's no way out for us.
We gotta duke it out.
Let's finish this before the air strike.
Oh boy.
This is the part I'm scared of too.
Hahaha.
I think since Vulcan Raven I've been scared of.
Stop looking at her like that.
You weirdo.
Which ending are we getting?
I'll be honest.
I don't know.
I honestly have no idea.
This nuclear module is set to detonate at the precise moment of her death.
No!
Well, then she won't die.
I was aiming for the Meryl ending because, you know, it's the canonic canon.
Oh, no, no, no.
If you win, you might still be able to say that.
Turn on!
My controller turned off.
You could enjoy one brief moment of love before the end.
Okay, we're good.
If you cross this line, you'll fall.
Yeah.
At this height, it will kill even you.
Even you.
Okay.
Come on.
Let me fight him already, please.
Why did they even start...
Have at you, Snake.
Why did they even start it at a...
Oh.
Oh, Snake.
Don't charge.
Yeah.
What's wrong, Snake?
Oh, shoot.
Yeah.
I got him.
No.
Yeah.
Try running.
Oh!
Why did I do that?
Ouch.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Why does he hit so much more than me?
So unfair.
Come on.
Oh, dang.
That was my...
That was my shot when he started running around.
No, no.
I won't let you.
Yeah.
Don't charge.
Why did I do that?
There's not a good way for me to... Oh my god!
Please!
I don't think I can under... I don't think I...
Oh my god!
I think the size is actually maybe throwing me off a little bit because I'm like kind of huge.
You know?
Don't charge at me.
I tried to avoid it.
Ouch!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Don't charge at me.
Yeah.
No one cries for me.
What if Liquid's just really short?
Short king.
Okay.
These stupid eye frames.
Oh!
Running away, are you?
You coward brother...
I hate...
This isn't CQC.
This is unfairness.
Why does he hit like three times harder than I do?
What's wrong, Snake?
You hit too hard!
That's what's wrong.
That's my problem, man.
That's my problem.
Why did that not hit you at all?
Why can I only get one-hitted?
Yeah.
What's wrong, Snake?
You're the one running!
Nice shot!
Hurry!
It's going to blow!
Oh my god.
What's wrong, Snake?
Why did you charge at me twice in a row?
What?!
Oh my god!
You guys, this will be the longest fight, I think.
This is... I don't even think I know.
I know this is going to be...
This is the longest... This is always the one that gets me.
Well, I say that.
This feels so unfair.
I know, right?
It really is.
It's literally just a get good.
But he has so... His eye frames last forever.
I think there's a way to like...
There's a way to like pin him and like get him kind of... Hello?
Go up?
Kind of get him in like a...
In like a one-two, one-two, one-two, you know?
Yeah.
But I just...
But he...
One-two.
Yeah, that's right.
Oh, oh.
One-two.
Yeah.
I'm not doing enough damage.
This sucks, man.
This sucks so much.
Ugh.
Yeah.
Oh, oh.
And I'm huge.
Are you gonna dodge it?
Oh my...
Yeah, that's right.
Try.
Ah!
How does he get me every time?
It's so hard to avoid his stupid dodge!
Oh my god.
Yeah, I gotta get him in like the corner of Rex.
But I don't know.
I'm not skilled enough to be... It's actually...
It's actually a skill issue.
I'm like actually not skilled enough to do it, I think.
Oh!
I'm out of life!
That's more like it!
I think he tapped me!
Well, remember what Miller said?
Liquid uses CQB, which hits harder.
Why didn't... Why didn't... Why wouldn't... Why didn't Dad teach us CQB?
Why does Big Boss hate us?
Why does he hate us?
Oh.
Shit.
Why does he hate us?
What's wrong, Snake?
I try... I like spam the button to be able to get in enough hits before the iframes kick in.
But...
But then this happens!
Stop it!
Yeah.
Don't charge.
Oh!
Did that hurt me for real?
I hate fighting you!
I'm...
This is Mint's Elden Ring.
Do throws not work on him?
No, they don't.
See?
Oh, see?
Like here.
One, two.
Oh.
Then he... he gets me.
I don't know what... like the angle or anything that he needs to be in in the court.
I have no idea.
So I'm not even gonna attempt.
See?
Like here.
It's perfect.
And then you...
One, two.
One...
But I... I just can't...
I can't get to him!
Get away!
Go... I mean...
Just die!
Why are you like...
Why are you like this?
Oh.
Sorry.
My bad.
We're fine.
Get him!
I think like...
Out of the whole game...
I know this is...
Oh my god.
I didn't realize.
I didn't realize we were at that point already.
This is definitely my least favorite fight...
In the whole game.
Because it just...
Feels very unfair.
It's so... It feels so unfair.
Because he's so manic!
He's so freaking manic!
Oh my god.
It's all... It's everything.
It's how hard he hits.
It's... It's...
It's the time limit.
It's just everything that is so hard for me.
I know next hit is gonna kill me.
See?
There...
Ugh.
It's not even the final boss!
Why did he get iframes there?
Oh my god.
Ugh.
That was the furthest I think I've gotten though.
I need to learn the...
The speedrunner way, you know?
The speedrunner way?
I don't understand this game.
Some of the...
Some of the enemies that I have to fight there.
And I only have one life left.
I don't have to another life.
That's not the point.
You just have to have the right move.
I mean, it's just...
I just have to...
You...
Oh!
I just let it happen.
I just... I just...
Oh!
Ouch!
Why can't I get more?
Why can't I get more hits?
It's so weird sometimes.
Oh my god!
Oh!
Like even if I do the one-two, I only get the one in.
There's... Oh my god!
Alright!
That's right!
Oh shoot!
Oh nice!
Nice!
God!
Oh my god!
Please!
Come on!
Get up!
Oh my god!
Ouch!
Oh shit!
Shit!
I know!
You're not helping!
Get up!
Please!
Oh my god!
You are so unfair, Liquid!
You are so unfair!
Oh my god!
Oh!
That was genuinely a great attempt.
Good job.
I was... I really was doing well in the beginning too.
Like I had no... no hits for a while.
Which was great.
Oh!
Oh bitch!
Words
hit!
This makes no sense!
World!
Oh maybe not that.
That's a bit of a dramatic... dramatization.
But...
But you know what I mean.
He's got them long legs.
Look at me though!
Ouch!
Look at my legs though!
They're much longer.
I'm way more agile.
I'm way more agile than this nerd.
It's so hard to read him.
It's so hard to read when he's gonna charge at me.
I...
I wasn't sure if he was gonna hit me so I...
Oh my god.
I have iframes too!
Let me use them!
Oh my god!
Come on!
Don't hit me twice.
It's so unfair.
I'm out of patience.
That's more... that's more what I'm out of.
I'm out of patience!
Stop hitting me twice!
Can anyone explain to me why sometimes my hits don't land and sometimes...
Is it because I'm too far away?
Is that the issue?
Why are you running?
See?
I think it's when he's blocking.
How can you tell though?
Wrong angle.
Too far away.
Bad angle.
You died again.
No fucking shit!
This is the fight I'm worst at in the game.
Anybody surprised by that?
Shit.
Hands can't reach.
Catch these hands!
So I just gotta get real close in on him.
Just gotta be like, hey baby girl!
Or not like that.
Why sometimes he gets iframes after one hit in phase two?
He frequently gets that and a free counter attack in that phase.
He generally will not if you hit him after and does a move of his own.
Wait so... wait what?
Hahaha.
I thought that was a...
I think I didn't understand.
But that's okay.
You tried helping.
I appreciate it.
Oh!
Whoopsie.
Get up.
Please don't.
Please don't charge me.
Yeah.
Okay.
We'll get him eventually though, guys.
Oh sh... God.
See?
There he goes again.
Bitches run around!
Are you gonna charge at me?
Felt like he was gonna charge at me.
There he goes.
Get up, Liquid!
Oh, why are you phased through the ground a little bit?
And I know he kicks over.
Ouch!
Told you we'd get him eventually.
Hahaha.
First try, baby!
Yippee!
Okay.
We're in the homestretch, everybody.
Meryl?
Uh-oh.
Meryl!
I didn't submit!
Damn!
I have to...
I gave in to my feelings.
I have to be on the planet without a god.
I sold your life to save my own.
It's the nerd ending.
I'm a loser.
I'm not the hero you thought I was.
For anybody who's joined later...
I'm nothing!
This is not the original save that I started from.
Basically, I started with the normal game.
I'm sorry.
Forgive me.
I started with the normal game.
And I did not submit.
I, uh...
Meryl can't forgive you anymore.
I made it through the torture.
But...
Um...
To play the mint model, I couldn't do it on the Master Collection.
So instead, they gave me a save that had the model in there.
I guess blaming yourself makes it easier.
And then...
Um...
And so I wasn't sure...
If you do that, you can keep the pain at a nice safe distance.
The save started me at Vulcan Raven, so I wasn't sure if...
What the hell do you know?
Meryl's dead!
Which one we would give...
I lost!
So...
Are you gonna stay here and die?
Along with her?
So anybody who came in late and was curious about why...
Snake...
I was like, which one are we gonna get?
It's gotcha!
People die.
Damn, Otacon.
But death is not defeat.
Damn, Otacon!
Dang, I kinda wanted to...
That's what Henry was saying.
I wanted to have the canon ending, though.
I lost Wolf to him.
But it's okay.
But that wasn't defeat.
Jeremy did this on purpose.
She and I will be together forever.
We didn't lose anything.
But that wasn't defeat.
Together forever.
It's true that Wolf is dead.
This is the canon ending.
Stop!
But our love didn't end with her.
Life's more than just a game of winning and losing.
Oh my god.
Otacon is consoling me.
Don't you think?
Let's live, Snake.
Look at Otacon.
He's consoling me.
There's a parking garage right next door.
We can get to the surface from there.
Can you imagine parking right next to Red?
Come on, Snake.
Come on.
Oh my god.
Merrill is so tiny.
I released all the security locks.
It'll be okay.
We can escape.
Merrill is so tiny.
Jeremy is like this.
You have my word on it.
Otacon.
You changed.
This is the canon ending for Solid Mint.
Yeah.
I'm through regretting the past.
Life isn't all about loss, you know?
Otacon, you changed.
It's sad.
To start it.
Ooh.
Those guys.
It seems like they only hurry when they're destroying things.
One true parent.
Good.
Let him destroy it.
Hey.
But they can't destroy the human spirit.
I also prefer this ending.
But you know.
Okay.
Let's go.
Merrill.
Uh.
It's jiggling.
I hope you're still watching me.
It's like vibrating on my...
Maybe I can prove myself to you all.
Shut up!
The GOGF is so unstable!
I would have had no cutscenes or something, you know?
Put on my sneaky suit!
It's vibrating against my thigh.
It feels nice, like a massage.
I didn't change anything!
Oh sorry, I have my little cat mouth now.
I'm more smug.
Merle had beer o'clock.
Call me!
Call!
Alrighty.
Awesome.
Hurry!
I'm going, I'm going!
Isn't there some stuff here?
Yeah.
Oh, I only have one ration.
I lost all my stuff.
Come on, let's go.
Don't alert the guards!
Why did you do that?
Otacon!
Where's the gun?
Otacon, where's the gun?
Oh my god!
Let's go!
Okay.
I think I forgot to get... wasn't there a second ration?
Uh-oh.
If we have to redo it, it's fine.
Good night!
Otacon, I'm ready to do it!
I'm ready to shoot him!
I'm ready to mow him down!
Oh!
Yeah!
I'm ready to mow him down!
Here, wait, which way does he... maybe this way.
I'm
trying!
I'm trying!
Snake, you've got a clear path!
These guys can eat bullets!
Was that the last one?
There we go.
Okay, here he comes.
Not yet, Snake!
It's not over yet!
Liquid!
Yeah!
Where's my body armor, huh?
I had all my stuff.
What did you do with my stuff, you stealer?
You stole my st... oh, ouch!
You stole my stuff!
Oh my god.
You thief!
You're such a thief!
Oh, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh my god.
Why'd you steal my stuff, Liquid?
You jerk!
Take him down!
Alarolcha, I'm hitting you!
Alarolcha!
Nyah!
Yeah, I'm ready for big boss rank.
Are you okay?
I guess so.
Otacon, don't.
Otacon, can you move?
It's embarrassing.
I'm in a skirt.
It's no use.
I can't move.
I'll lift the car.
I'm strong.
What happened to Liquid?
I don't know, but I hope he's dead.
Thank you for the super diet!
Liquid's dead.
Finally.
Uh oh.
Oh my god.
Snake!
Look at me.
He hates anime.
Die.
Janna!
No, I'm just kidding.
Oh, he's...
My waifu.
Yeah!
Now he's dead!
Woohoo!
If he's dead, that means...
Oh.
Oh, wait.
That means about me?
Oh, no.
Don't think about it, Snake.
Aww.
What happened to the air raid?
No stealth bombers in sight.
Yeah.
Snake, can you hear me?
Colonel, are you okay?
Actually, this ending is better because Otacon gets to be with anime.
Early retirement.
It works.
Arrested?
I was able to get into contact with the President.
Oh, nice!
Metal gear, the training exercise, all of it.
It was all the Secretary of Defense acting alone.
Acting alone?
What happened to the air raid?
And the nuclear strike?
He called it off.
The orders were rescinded.
Yippee!
The F-117s and the B-2 Spirits have returned to the base.
Everything's good!
Once again, I have complete authority over this operation.
Colonel.
I see.
Washington isn't stupid enough to use nukes to cover up a few secrets.
I wonder about that.
Yeah, I do too.
In any case, the danger's over.
Yeah.
Thanks, Snake.
Colonel, about Meryl.
About Meryl.
I already know.
Colonel.
Meryl was my daughter.
What?
We killed his daughter!
I didn't find out until recently.
I got a letter from her mother.
My dead brother's wife.
I was going to tell her after this operation was over.
Uh-oh.
Colonel, I...
It's okay, Snake.
Thanks anyway.
Snake.
I'm sorry.
I...
I kept a lot of things from you.
It's okay, Colonel.
Snake.
Are you always fated to get the Otacon?
I'm not a Colonel.
Okay, Colonel.
I've got a present for you.
There's a snowmobile close to you.
Mei Ling saw it on the satellite photos.
This time of year, the glaciers are pretty calm.
I actually like Meryl.
You should be able to ride right out of there.
I'll bet the boys at the D.I.A.
and the N.S.A.
never expected you to come home alive.
Me neither.
I better not show my face around here.
I'm sorry.
No danger of that.
You two officially died after your jeep sank into the ocean.
That's not too far from the truth.
Also, there's a helicopter waiting for you on Fox Island.
Fox Island.
Okay, Roy.
Roy.
Are you going to be okay?
Don't worry.
I've got an insurance policy, a hard copy of all Mei Ling's data.
Whoa.
As long as I've got that, you, me, and Mei Ling will be fine.
Mei Ling saving the day.
The battery on these nanomachines will run out soon.
They won't be able to follow us.
I guess we won't meet again.
Don't worry.
I'll pay you a visit sometime.
Really?
I'll look forward to that.
Roy, just tell me one thing.
What?
About Fox Die.
Yeah.
What about me?
It killed Liquid.
Naomi said that she wants to talk to you face to face about that.
Oh, great.
How is she?
Don't worry.
Mei Ling is with her right now.
Snake is so much better than me.
I need to go to Naomi.
I need to learn to be more like Snake.
Snake, it's me.
Naomi.
I heard about my brother.
He doesn't think that Naomi is so annoying.
I'm sorry.
But he had one last message he wanted to say to you.
What?
He told me to tell you to forget about him and to go on with your own life.
Snake, you're such a good person.
Frankie said that?
You're such a good person.
Yeah.
You're such a good guy.
He also said he'll always love you.
You're such a good guy, Snake.
Naomi.
She didn't deserve it.
Your brother just said that.
He has saved you, me, and the whole world.
She doesn't deserve those nice lies, man.
He fought with every ounce of strength in his body.
She doesn't deserve it.
He's such a good guy.
Maybe now he's finally found some peace.
He wasn't really my brother anymore.
Ever since he fought with you in Zanzibar, he's been like a ghost.
A ghost looking for a place to die.
I'm sorry.
Like a ghost's ghost.
Okay.
Shut up.
Naomi, liquid died from Fox die, too.
Yeah.
It's kind of important.
What about me?
When am I going to go?
That's up to you.
What do you mean?
Oh, God.
Everybody dies when their time is up.
Yeah, but Naomi, I have a virus in me.
Yeah.
So when's mine up?
Naomi.
It's up to you how you use the time left to you.
Naomi!
That's not...
This is...
Live, Snake.
It's all I can say to you.
Oh my god.
She's just so awful!
Oh my god!
Each person is born with their fate written into their own genetic code.
It's unchangeable, immutable.
But that's not all there is to life.
I finally realized that.
Naomi, please, how long do I have?
You created this virus!
You gave it to me!
What?
How long do I have?
Because I wanted to know who I was.
Where I came from.
But what about me, Naomi?
You're so selfish.
I thought if I analyzed my DNA I could find out who I was.
Who my parents were.
Oh my god.
And I thought that if I knew that, then I'd know what path I should take in life.
Just live.
Just live, forehead.
I didn't find anything.
You're talking to me!
I'm talking to Otacon!
Just like with the genome soldiers, you can input all the genetic information but that doesn't make them into the strongest soldiers.
The most we can say about DNA is that it governs a person's potential strengths.
Potential destiny.
You mustn't allow yourself I have no idea on this.
to be ruled by your genes.
Humans can choose the type of life they want to live.
Smug.
Snake, whether or not you're in the Foxdive program isn't important.
Don't trip.
The important thing is that you choose life.
And then live.
Live.
Don't you think, Snake?
Oh, oh, oh!
I'm going to choose life too.
Until today I've always looked for a reason to live.
Oh, brother.
But from here on, I'm going to just live.
Look at us going down the little hill together.
We're so cute.
She keeps going, man.
She just keeps on going.
Yay!
Snowmobile!
Living is a link to the future.
That's how all life works.
Loving each other.
Teaching each other.
Sorry, when it says loving each other and looks at Otacon, please!
This game!
They know what they're doing.
I finally realized it.
The true meaning of life.
What is she yapping about?
Thank you, Snake.
That's me.
Thank you, Mint.
Oh, I'm driving.
Oh my gosh!
I don't know how to...
Until today, I've lived only for myself.
Survival has been the only thing I cared about in my life.
That's not just you.
That's how everyone is.
I only felt truly alive when I was staring death in the face.
I don't know.
Maybe it's written into my genes.
What about now?
I want to enjoy life.
I really do.
Aww.
How about you, Otacon?
Me?
I feel like a new man.
So what are you going to do?
Continue your research?
No, I'm finished with science.
I'm interested in human psychology now.
Wow.
Sounds good.
The whole reason I got into science in the first place was because I was no good with people.
Aww.
I was scared of them.
Same.
It's okay.
I was scared of life.
Same.
Well, you know.
I thought that I could never understand them because they're so illogical.
But I finally learned how to like people.
You don't need people.
You have an anime waifu now.
I'm not afraid anymore.
It's okay.
You and I are more alike than I thought.
I'm just tired of always being a spectator in life.
I'm ready to live.
I'm going to stand on my own two feet.
Aww.
I'm not going to hide anymore.
You giving up your stealth camo?
Huh?
Can I have it?
Oh yeah.
You can have it.
Yippee!
Oh my god.
Beaks kill my heart.
This is where we say goodbye to our loves as well.
Want me to drive?
No thanks.
I'd rather do it myself.
No problem.
Where to, Snake?
Oh.
My real name is Mint Otacon.
I'm Hal, Dave.
Well, that's right.
Hal.
Hal and Dave.
That's a good one.
And Mint.
Maybe we should take a trip to Jupiter.
So where you going, Dave?
Mint.
I think it's time for me to look for a new path in life.
A new path?
There's such dorks.
A new purpose.
Will you find it?
I'll find it.
What does that mean?
It's a reference to...
I know I'll find it.
To...
Odyssey.
2000.
Oh my gosh.
A space odyssey.
2001.
Sorry.
A space odyssey.
Yay!
In the 1980s there were more than 60,000 nuclear warheads in the world at all times.
The total destructive power amounted to 1 million times that of the Hiroshima A-bomb.
In January 1993 START II was signed and the United States and Russia agreed to reduce the number of deployed strategic nuclear warheads to 3,000 to 3,500 by December something...
December 3rd.
However, as of 1998 there still exists 26,000 nuclear warheads in the world.
And...
Ugh.
Text too fast.
Ah!
Congrats on being in the game.
Thank you, Nashi!
Boo, politics?
Yo, don't get into Metal Gear then.
Metal Gear is all politics.
I love this song so much.
Congrats on the cabinet.
Ah!
Liquid...
Beating Liquid up was the hardest boss.
Ow!
Thanks for the five gifted!
How much gas is in that snowmobile?
They're going to Fox Island.
There's a helicopter.
There's a helicopter there.
Looks bad.
CQC rad.
Details inside.
Here it goes.
That was early.
We did it!
Whatever it is!
Chuu!
New headcanon minted as a ghost because Otacon fell in love with it.
Oh my god, that's brutal.
Congrats on being in the game again.
Thank you!
Didn't have comedic Otacon fall.
So true.
Oh, little go-
Oh, this song makes me cry.
Panda!
Thanks for the 20 gifted!
Thank you!
S1, thank you for the 10.
Thank you so much.
Man...
Mint mod made this 10 times better.
I thought it would be fun to kind of...
It wasn't my intention to save it for the finale but...
I really wanted to make it possible for the finale.
If you heard that, that was my controller disconnecting.
Haha...
Ha...
Oooh, it's a moose!
I mean, just a singular moose.
Mushroom!
You protected the world from devastation.
United all nations within our...
Wait...
Within our nation.
Renounced the evils of truth and love.
Extended our reach to the skies above.
Minto!
Otacon!
United all nations within our nation.
Wait, is that actually it?
You know this place is kind of beautiful.
No, I don't mean the flaming wreckage of dead bodies we left behind us.
I mean Alaska!
Metal Gear...
Mega64's Metal Gear Solid in 5 minutes.
Actually, Mega64 will be at MGSCon.
And they, like, Rocko tweeted out, he was just like, getting ready for MGSCon, we realized that we save everything.
And so, I wonder what they'll be bringing to the convention.
I wonder maybe some secret stuff from when they did like the commercials.
Like some props and stuff when they did the commercials for MGS4.
It's pretty neat.
I always preferred the commercials.
Can and Meryl ending since Otacon gets the cool self-sacrifice moment.
I mean...
He doesn't sacrifice himself.
I mean, he still lives.
But you know, I get it.
Congrats on beating MGS and getting an otaku BF!
I would tame Otacon, I would.
Very close to finishing Peace Walker.
The ending of Peace Walker is so...
frustrating.
And so good.
And so beautiful.
I love it, I love it.
Thank you for all the superchats!
Raven's choice of the GAU-8 as his main weapon is comical.
It's too heavy, ammo hungry, and long to be useful in this boss arena.
I mean, it's a good workout, you know?
Will you play as the angsty pretty boy next?
Of course!
So not this Saturday, but next Saturday.
The 13th.
We will continue Metal Gear Saturdays.
With...
Wait.
Yeah.
The 13th with Metal Gear Solid 2!
I wish I had started it in April.
So I could play it on April 30th.
But that's okay too.
Octopus Pie!
Big shoutouts to Virasek and...
Jebbles?
Yes!
Thank you, Virasek!
Thank you, Jeremy.
Thank you both so, so, so much for putting this all together.
Doing the...
Virasek, you are so cracked.
You are...
I remember when the tweet went out about the mod, multiple people messaged me being like Did you see this?
You mustn't allow yourself to be chained to fate.
To be ruled by your genes.
Humans can choose the type of life they want to live.
It's like a dream come true, honestly.
Seeing myself in the game.
So thank you!
The important thing is that you choose life.
And then live.
Thanks, Naomi.
Metal Gear Solid...
Yes, sir.
The entire unit was wiped out.
No, sir.
Still alive.
The Vector?
Yes, sir.
Right on schedule.
I recovered all of Rex's dummy warhead data.
No, sir.
My cover is intact.
Nobody knows who I really am.
Yes, sir.
Yes, the DARPA chief knew my identity.
But he's been disposed of.
Yes, sir.
Yes.
Thank you.
I'm getting it right.
Mr. President.
What's that?
Ocelot talking to the President?
What does that mean?
Oh, wait.
This isn't my...
Wait.
This isn't my save.
What would I have been?
I guess we'll never know.
No.
In my free time, I'll beat it on my normal account.
Not account.
On my normal... on the Master Collection.
And I'll tell you guys.
I'll beat it in my... well, whenever I have free time.
I'll beat it in my...
well, whenever I have free time.
But I'll let you guys know.
I'll let you guys know.
What does leopard mean anyway, though?
Finishing the game in 5 hours is nuts?
No, no.
I did not do that.
Cat.
No.
Shut up, you guys.
Shut up!
Really good stats.
Well.
I had to still have really good stats to finish the game.
So...
Yippee!
Oh.
There we go.
Connected.
Yes.
The end credits song was sung in Irish.
I know.
That's why I've never sung it before.
I've seen...
What's Pocket Station?
The Story Card.
I've seen some English covers done of The Best Is Yet To Come.
But...
Hmm...
Uh...
But...
Um...
I don't know.
I would have to...
I feel like I would have to mess around with it a little bit.
I know Donna Burke has one too.
So...
I'm just gonna go to here.
Oh!
Demo!
Wait.
Does this work?
Oh.
It's just the Otacon ending.
Never mind.
The original just hits.
It really does.
One player view mode.
What is that anyway?
Well guys!
I did it!
Good work boss!
Thank you!
Even with performance anxiety!
First person view?
Wait.
No way.
I wanna see what it's like.
Very important to me ever since I was 8 years old.
I'm so happy.
To be...
Oh no!
It's telling me to...
Telling me to put a disc one.
Oh.
There is no...
Ah.
Well.
Alt F4 time.
You know what?
That's fine.
We finished it.
Goodbye Metal Gear.
No.
Don't leave me Metal Gear.
I love you Metal Gear!
I love you Metal Gear.
Ah man.
I'm gonna move you guys.
I can't talk for too long.
Just because I have...
To get ready for...
Leaving.
We can talk a little bit.
Okay.
Congrats on beating the game.
Will you be doing Ghost Bobble before or after MGS2?
Oh!
Oh.
Whoops.
No.
Not my headband.
My headband and ammo.
Um.
Probably after.
I'll probably go through the main series.
And then do the other games.
Like Acid and Ghost Bobble and stuff like that.
So it's a treat to watch.
Looking forward to the rest of the franchise.
I could honestly watch people play these games forever.
There's...
Yeah!
Me too!
Just wanna let you know...
Oh wait.
Hold on.
Let me put on some music real quick.
Let me put on some music.
There we go.
I have started the first part of rendering the beeswax!
It's like a few days to get to the point where I can make it into a candle.
I'll be blessed to update you.
Oh my gosh!
Let's go!
Beeswax!
Andr goes thanks for the pink!
It was so much fun watching you play through the game.
Thanks for the stream.
Looking forward to the next game.
Thank you!
Nibi!
I'm glad that...
Um...
That...
I didn't take like two hours on Rex.
I'm glad.
Great job, boss!
I can't make it to the concert, but I'll be cheering in spirit.
Hope you have time to visit AX and pick up some merch.
I think BA is going to have a booth.
They are!
I honestly don't even know if I'm going to be able to go to the con.
I actually have so much to do.
So I'm just kind of like...
But if I do, cool.
If I don't, that's okay too.
Honestly, if I don't, it saves me a big headache from having to walk into AX.
So, honestly...
It's worth.
Tomorrow, I have my first ever...
Wait, hold on.
I have my first ever...
Vlog!
I went to a maid cafe!
And I am reporting on it.
So...
If you are watching an AX war...
Or not even just AX war...
Just watch it.
Vlog!
I possessed someone and I made her go for me.
So...
I'm just like...
I'm like inside this...
They never knew that I was a ghost the whole time.
They never knew...
That I was a ghost inside someone's body.
Did you ask for consent?
I'm sure she enjoyed the trip.
I wonder if Mint will ever watch Escape from L.A.
No, no.
Not Escape from L.A.
Escape from New York!
The actual movie that inspired the Solid series.
I have seen Escape from New York though.
I have not seen Escape from L.A.
Which is Escape from New York 2.
But I have, I have.
I'm gonna commission art in advance of you playing Acid in my ongoing campaign to girl boss, gatekeep, and gaslight you into playing Acid too.
I will play Acid eventually.
I'm gonna not enjoy it.
I'm not gonna have fun with Acid.
But I will play it.
Fake fan corrected.
I...
Am a ffff...
Fan.
I was not gonna say...
I was like I am a fake fan.
But then I was like, wait a second.
No, I'm not.
Thanks for reminding me about AX.
I will be avoiding downtown L.A.
on Friday.
But that's where...
My concert is.
Theocrats.
We have to go.
Or not.
You don't have to go.
But you know.
It will be fun.
It will be a fun time.
Yeah.
I will be performing at a concert on Friday.
Which I'm very excited about.
I'm very nervous about.
I was practicing today.
And everything.
But I have to also pack.
Oh my god.
No!
I have to throw the rest of my laundry in the...
In the dryer!
Okay guys.
I gotta get going.
So I can make sure that my clothes dry on time.
Thank you guys for Metal Gear Solid.
I hope you guys were surprised by the Minto model.
I hope it was fun for you.
And we did it baby!
In less than 4 hours.
Got through Vulcan Raven.
The Palkis.
Rex.
Liquid.
The car.
We did it baby.
We did it.
Good job to us.
Thank you so much.
And I hope you guys have a great night.
A great day.
If you are in the United States.
I hope you have tomorrow off.
And yeah.
I'm gonna go finish getting ready.
Oh my god.
Good night everyone!
Good night!
And...
I'll see you.
What was I gonna say?
I'll see you...
Maybe Sunday.
Maybe Monday.
I'm not sure yet.
I'm gonna try.
Maybe I can do a gorilla stream on Sunday.
I'll see how I'm feeling.
Cause it'll be a busy busy weekend.
Anyway.
See you next week!
Bye bye!
See you in a few days!
See you!
Bye bye!
Guys why is it every time I go to Twitter I just see like People's Art of Doki Booze.
What's going on?
I'm not consenting to this.
I just see Doki's boobs all over my timeline.
Why is this happening to me?
I don't know.
Why are they all over my timeline?
Her birthday is tomorrow.
So she's in her birthday suit.
Is that what you're telling me?
Did she do one too?
No I'm saying nip out.
I keep seeing art of her with nip out.
Doki put on a shirt!
Anyway.
Not good.
They are for humans.
I don't want that!
I never asked for this!
Oh yeah wait I did see Oimo's.
I thought you meant that she did like a NSFW one.
No I saw that one too!
Blink so I can avoid.